[Music]
we start
awkwardly they end awkwardly um
wild this is wild this is a wild episode
this is already my favorite episode of
the podcast
it i'm i'm overwhelmed let's just go
around and say how we're feeling i feel
overwhelmed uh
i'm like nervously excited in a good way
um i'm this is a powerful moment
two virgo witches in the same room
uh the woman who
is my real life
virgo sister past life twin
who i cast to play my best friend in a
television
show because i wanted her to be my best
friend in real life and then it
happened and then she remade
the movie that made me
who i am
what is that what is there a word for
that
uh for ayahuasca for everything you just
said is there one word is there a word
for that like what are you to me what's
our relationship
that's the first thing i ask everyone is
are we friends what's our relationship
well we're obviously friends
that friends is calling me your friend
is so insulting
i know i don't know what the word is it
is like
joey lister jones who played my best
friend
on the lauded tv show whitney uh
we are what are we to each other we died
together in pompeii
yeah family yeah we're three days apart
yeah
september 1st september 4th we had our
30th birthday together
we did at a shitty bar yes with robin
the soundtrack was robbed the soundtrack
was robin i was like
i threw my back out dancing to dancing
on my own uh-huh
yeah um we played rihanna birthday cake
yes we did uh when our cakes
yes we found love in a hopeless place
yeah it's our anthem
it is yeah i have almost pulled an
achilles tendon
dancing to love in a hopeless place
um with zoey between scenes
of the tv show whitney yes benton what
do you can you describe our relationship
because we can't find the words
i don't know that's so nice you guys
forgetting to do all that during those
songs
i worked at the mall so that must be
nice
you were at journeys you were working
with georgia
but you were a fan of the show whitney
yes i was i used to write down the
the lines you would say to figure out
how to write a script when i was a
freshman in college
so you would write down whitney and
lily's lines so you
you've watched our friendship yeah i did
in real time i didn't know it was real
when i was watching it was on tv yeah so
that's shocking to find out
and what happened with zoe which is so
important because when esther came on
the podcast
she brought up she was like we need to
revisit that show
she goes we need to revisit how sexist
that whole thing was
the mass the salem witch
trials the mass shaming of me yeah
a woman who didn't want to get married
it was
they didn't like it because it was
supposed to be a gender reversal yeah
the man was the woman and the woman was
the man
right and the um
public shaming
it it it happened to lana del rey kind
of around the same time
when she went on snl that uh it became
the
um gladiator show like i was in the
gladiator show of ancient rome like i
feel like i was
in a weird way like the first person to
be canceled or something we all but
through tomatoes
well yeah you were also you were also
like
wildly successful very young i was also
loud
and unapologetic and you were like
forging your own
can isn't it funny that you say i'm
unapologetic when i
at that time was like sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry i was the most i was
so sorry for my existence i just
ostensibly
yes per maybe personally but i felt like
professionally you were not sorry for
your existence you were
like bold in the way that we all should
be you know like you were like you had
three shows in production at the same
time
how dare she that and yeah and i think
there was a lot of how dare she
how dare she who does she think she is
if i wasn't me that's what i would have
thought
yeah it was interesting and i in it i
mean i mean i'm very triggering to
people
i think i was very triggering to people
i had an eating disorder at the time i
was incredibly thin i was loud
um and it was actually
so interesting to me because it was
created by a woman
it was written by a woman uh starring
the same woman starring the same woman
yeah it was a female showrunner
half the writer's room was a woman and
then emily nussbaum
said that i was sexist
what's happening he's a critic for the
uh new york poster times or one of those
things that
is i think still in business just
because they take money from lawyers
that pay off
them how else would they have money so
look at that they said you were allowed
they said you were annoying they said
you had an eating disorder please don't
is your finger coming over this camera
thank you thank you
virgo they said you had an eating
disorder mm-hmm i had no i had an eating
disorder
but they said i was well i remember
remember the reviews there was a review
that was like about my appearance like
if we were to pull up those reviews now
of men reviewing my appearance in the
show
talking about my body yeah in a like a
new york times review
and that happened a lot i think it still
happens i mean that's the thing about
like
there's so much like latent uh
misogyny that's happening at all
internalized misogyny that women have
yeah i think
i think for me the biggest awakening
i've had and in watching your movie the
craft which is out now
um it's
we women internalized it too yes oh 100
so the line in the movie women won't use
their power against each other
what is the line yeah david company's
character yeah
david says um i wrote it down and sorry
yeah
women the thing the thing about women
with power is that um
they'll always use it against each other
which was not that is not my perspective
that was him like gaslighting mm-hmm
uh the character that kelly spain plays
but i do think that that also does
happen
i think that like i realized that i had
internalized so much misogyny
and that i was sexist too but other like
the people that hurt me the most were
women
the women that came for me you know um
but zoe played my best friend on the
show
do you remember what happened when we
met yeah of course
first of all changed my life there's
there's a lot of things also the house i
live in i say to everyone that's the
house that whitney built
because it's true because i was a
working actor and this is the house
itself
um i was working actor but couldn't i
wasn't making like a
proper living at it and i was just
hustling
so hard and going to so many auditions
and i could not get
on a series and that was like what i
wanted and then
i showed up you flew to new york
um and i came into the room no you're
missing
many things no i'm not you're missing
the kris jenner part where i made you
dye your hair no that was after
you came to the room two virgos she came
to the room
don't interrupt me sorry
mommy spirit um you get to do this time
yeah it's my day my turn anyway
so um you can see why you came to new
york
and i walked in i remember uh at nbc
and i sat down and you said um why
aren't you famous yet
i was like so i was like both moved and
insulted i said why aren't you famous
what's going on yeah
which is like yeah and i didn't i didn't
have an answer and when he was like well
then
like let's work on that together
basically and then i said
uh okay you've been with someone for
eight years
and you're not married that's what this
show's about
oh my god i don't remember that that's
right and i said why aren't you guys
engaged and zoe said because i'm waiting
till he can afford the ring i deserve
[Music]
she said i'm waiting till he can afford
the ring i deserve
not no pause no stutter nothing
came out and then i remember the
literally the audition scene i had seen
when you're auditioning
i mean you see hundreds and hundreds of
people all great
great people don't get jobs for many
reasons
because you're when you audition for a
job you're
coming in to play something that i
imagine so everyone's going to be
disappointing
yeah right yeah and i had never had a
friend before
so i was writing friends and didn't know
what they were
um it was a science fiction show
[Laughter]
um and the first two lines of the lilly
character
which is so funny that the lead
character in your movie's name is lily
so wild
so what i can make that connection i did
like everything
is connected yeah i know because as soon
as it was like hi lily i was like
that was zoe's name in my show okay got
it got it got it
um and uh we're in a simulation
um
um the lines were
high p the first line of lily's
character zoe's character was high
period high period
right and and most actors will come and
just go hi hi
and zoe did a reversal turn what do you
call it as an actress i don't even know
i don't know what did i she just went hi
hi like she did her you did a reversal
and she made
something she used her witchcraft um
and because you're already a writer
director and
in your brain you were already so
you made a straight line a joke
oh and that was it and then
and then she and then she paid for me to
go get my hair dyed
because we looked too similar because of
our our coloring
and because i hadn't met you yet and i
tried to hire june rayfield
and they said we look too similar
coloring-wise yeah because the way that
network television hires
is based on optics of checking boxes
right and all the
white people aren't allowed to look like
the same white people right
so we so you paid for me to get my to
dye my hair red
before the test i hadn't gotten the job
you understand so whitney was like
shelling out money
like she there was already did not have
you didn't have but i knew you were
gonna get it if you didn't look like me
and then the 10 and then i hired i had
so we used to test
you used to do something called a test
which is that you would have three
actresses come in
in front of the network and they would
all audition god it's so surreal to
think about now i know
you go in in person it's in front of a
bro
in front of a bunch of sexual predators
essentially
and um i
brought in a decoy yeah the worst
actress i saw i called in to test
against zoe so that the choice would be
obvious
so i had to trick them it was truly the
greatest gift anyone's ever given me
and her because her quote she got to
have a what happened is you would get a
right
right right and she got to test for
something right so we
build her self-esteem she didn't know
she was a decoy
no i don't regret that one bit jennifer
lawrence
you're welcome never worked here welcome
um
yes and then yeah it was like a worked
out perfectly it was
witchcraft magic it was unbelievable and
it was like
you know it's those any of any dream
that comes true or you're just like been
waiting for it for so long
and then it like happens it was just
like but it happened it didn't happen
like from luck it happened from
you believing in me and like fighting
for me and that's what's like so deeply
moving and i will cry multiple times
during this
oh trust me trust me because it is like
when you talk about women supporting
women like it was
it was just such it was the it's the
greatest gift anyone's ever given me
really because it it opened every door
for me
as a television actor which is how i
have been able to
um support myself yeah
yeah thank you for making it that's so
easy
and then it's interesting because i
think about you and our relationship is
so
complicated yeah because
when i was doing that show i was
unconscious
i was so scared yeah and so run by my
character defects and inner child
and programming and alcoholic um
ghosts like you were also under an
extreme amount of pressure and under a
microscope i was just
it was it was a combination of so many
yeah
it was just a confluence of like all the
um
you know dark forces but i was um
it was very much my inner child was
running the show yeah
and what i like to say is like the pan
my my inner child got covered and died
and now i'm in my adult like the
pandemic killed my inner child and now
i'm
an adult oh i'm waiting for mine to go
yeah i know i can i can
get them i can we can abort that
i think we can abort your inner child
here today could use that
how's that work but i was my fear was
running the show
and i was also so uncomfortable being
in a position of power i was i i was in
a position of i was thrust into a
position of power
um so quickly and i didn't
want power i wanted love and when you're
in a position of power especially as a
loud woman and you're taking up space
people resent you so i found myself like
all of a sudden i'm
in a position of power and it's actually
making me feel more abandoned and alone
when the whole reason i created this
whole thing was to
pay people to love me i mean it's really
what i did it's really subconsciously
what i
why i became a writer and made this show
is i didn't have a family i didn't have
the love i wanted i wrote the life i
wanted
and then the making of the show was the
fan you're really if you're set
in your crew it's your family absolutely
yeah and then i
wrote the best friend i wanted and then
i hired the best friend i wanted in real
life
i mean it's really it's really
profound it is and then and then
our relationship starts getting fucked
up because now i'm your boss
yeah and we aren't equals yeah haven't
we all been there
[Laughter]
yeah and then the added complication of
being
two women that are and now and i'm your
boss so you can never have a pure
relationship yeah but i will say
to both of our credits that
when you have a friend who you can call
and be like i'm so fucking mad at you
yes
here's why like there were that's real
during the two seasons of whitney yeah
we called each other screaming i mean
there were screaming matches you know
they were also crying matches i
just remember weeping a lot yeah
yeah um because my inner child is just
like always and what was i doing because
i was i was not i was so
in what was because i i remember a
specific one where we got a
pickup like we got a pickup order or
something and i didn't tell you guys
about it
and you found out oh my god i see i
don't even remember that i remember
everything and that and i got upset
yeah yeah you called like on behalf of
the whole cast
love to be a spokesperson like i didn't
tell you it's like virgo i got this
by the time you guys figure out what to
say i could have already done it that's
just virgo witch
101 that is for sure but it was like i
had not
i didn't know how to be a boss i wasn't
an adult i didn't know
i was so distracted i was it was also a
time where i was
i had such chronic migraines because of
my unrecovered codependence
and chemical and value you know i was
like you know i was a zombie
yeah and well i and i just remember in
the um
hair and makeup room like
that's like this like moment where
especially on tape night when you're
shooting live which what we did
it was like everyone's like buzzy buzzy
buzzy you're getting the energy up
and you at the beginning of the show
which you learned what you needed but
you were like
no one can speak and so in makeup before
shooting and so we would all
sit there quietly you know because you
were
okay so this was what i thought was
this is before i understood that all
humans just need to be seen recognized i
didn't know
i didn't understand yeah and i went i'm
so
i have so little bandwidth 100 the hair
and makeup room
should be quiet my codependency i
thought i was helping everyone i thought
i was liberating everyone from the
pressure to do small talk
because the hair and makeup room is
chaotic and there is that pressure
but it's also everyone has different
creative processes some people need to
be like celebrating and processing yeah
yeah and i
and i was also writing the script for
the next that's what i'm saying we all
understood
but this is again to your credit you
then were like you know what i'm gonna
go
get my own hair makeup room uh-huh which
is what was perfect because then you
were taking and i'm not
yeah i know but you weren't you were our
boss i mean you're a boss and are
listen i've had to direct people who are
in my cast
i mean and they're they're it's an
interesting thing because this is what
because zoey als is directs wright stars
in her own movies
and i remember when dan o'brien who
played mark on the show
the police officer that was a network
note i shouldn't have taken
came and looked like a stripper looked
like i mean if
if someone in a police uniform shows up
at the door it's like
are you in the ymca is this halloween
like it was like
shouldn't have taken that note brilliant
actor he i remember we're like in a
scene together
and i was like oh let's do let's add
this and he was like i can't do this
he's like a you know he's a very serious
he was like i can't
like he i remember him like snapping one
day yeah and it like shattered me
yeah um because i didn't know how to fix
it
and i had such deep emotional
perfectionism like i just
was like well yeah and all of us also
really wanted to please you
so it was that so it was that like it
which i never
thought i like at that point in my life
everyone's behavior was personal to me
i thought anytime someone yeah you know
what i mean it's like it's before i
understood
that everyone's doing the best they
could i i i still have a hard time
understanding that interesting yeah
intro right i take everything personally
it's hard
yeah it's hard like i take people's
fashion choices personally
i take people's noise personally you
know i do i think it's like
and it's it's a special form of
narcissism with me
because it's like what how did they they
should have known what should they have
known
it's because we're writers and we
control
our environment so much in what we do
and that when someone does something
that we didn't want it's like did you
not get the salmon pages like right
you know what i mean well there's also
like i have the thing of like
i'm an incredi i'm in in an incredibly
vulnerable space
and you should know that and you should
be you should know you know
and like i have a hard time being like
what's going on
maybe this is a narcissistic me you know
what's going on with you that you're not
responding to me
do you know like i have these things of
like i have i have a big trigger
with people who don't text me back in
how much time do they
how much time are they allowed to have
yes before you start to feel
abandoned rejected which is it uh
abandoned and rejected
and i go into shame like i did something
wrong interesting
and that is from being a woman and
everything we do is wrong
um yeah like i'm that's this is my
current journey
is like where is where where does that
shame
live and why and how do i like talk to
that person
who's like dealing with so much shame
all the time yeah because i go there
so quickly yep um my default emotion to
shame my default emotion is
embarrassing embarrassing it's my fault
yeah it's my fault and i
and i deserve it too like interesting
but then also like the like uh how dare
you
at the same time i'm like i deserve it
and also i'm a piece of shit in this
fuck you
i'm a piece of shit in the center of the
universe yeah i'm a piece of shit in the
center of the universe
yeah and then what my tinder bio
and that's so interesting and then and
then what happens because when yeah if
someone doesn't text me back i will
and were fantasy people this is but
and i think this is so important to get
granular with because
all of this is what makes you such a
great artist as well
it's what makes you because you are one
of the most sensitive people i know
and that's not and that's saying a lot
like whitney knows a lot of
fucking sensitive ass people but
sensitive is and this is why
the craft and what we're about to get
into with the craft is so important
because
women have been taught to believe that
their superpowers are weaknesses
yeah and they've been pathologized
you're sensitive you're hyper vigilant
that means you're crazy that means
you're psycho that means you're annoying
that means you're exhausting all those
things
but sensitivity is actually um the
biological basis for it
it is what helped our species
proliferate we rid the alarm system
there's a line there's a tiger what's
that wrestling in the bushes like
sensitivity is like so you're actually
a superhero like your high anxiety
people
are the most highly uh uh resilient to
people the ones that would have
you would have nailed it 2 000 years ago
you would have kept everyone a lot
you're just alive at the wrong time
it's just that the world changed do you
know what i mean yeah yeah
perfectly evolved to live in the woods
alone
cause now while you're shooting movies
like the craft
if you just want to exit now that
answers a lot of questions because your
ability to
threat detection and anticipate people's
needs and question other people's
motives that's what we do all day you're
scanning scanning scanning
yes i'm scanning and we've talked about
this too because like you taught me a
lot about this which is like
um because of like my inner child who's
very much
still alive maybe she won't be by the
end of today but
i'm pro choice when it comes to
inner child so um like i
um yeah i guess
the um what am i trying to say here
like i guess my my inner child is always
on high alert for danger everywhere and
that is like something that like every
therapist has always but why wouldn't
you be
you're well exact woman i think because
of my childhood because of where i grew
up like
brooklyn in the 80s was a scary place
yeah
um to grow up and and i think
like what every therapist i've ever had
has told me to do which i
like intellectually very much understand
but cannot embody still as a 38 year old
woman
i mean 27. um i whitney and i are 27.
um wait i'm three days older than you
yeah
that's why i'm her authority that like
three days later
i'm three days more sensitive
um that like i i don't know how to not
know
i i don't know how to not believe
that that there is danger everywhere you
know and so
and my reactivity is yeah is that
everything is like
a five alarm fire and you're not
wrong though the only thing we're wrong
about
is thinking that anticipating it
um uh taking up bandwidth thinking about
it is going to
prevent it from happening do you know
what i mean right so it's like that's
the only place where we have bad math so
it's like
i loved it i love to call it bad math
it's just helpful so it's like
um q anon the people that believe
q and on they're right they just have
the wrong facts uh-huh
so we'd all be cueing on they believe
they're saving children
right correct that pedophilia is bad
they think they're saving children
they're we're the same as them right we
have
everything in common you just have bad
math in terms of values
yeah right we have the same democratic
party as not a satanic affiliate cult
yeah no they just have bad they just got
the wrong information right they just
have fake news
if we thought that we'd do the same
thing we just don't think that because
it's not true
right right so it's like uh
you know we have bad our our primordial
reptile brain
says you need to constantly ascertain
and scan for this threat
over and over again in order to protect
yourself because our brain is only
designed for survival
that's it not any of this stuff not in
texting or phones or
our mcdonald doesn't even know what this
is right so it's like
um our brain rightly so
wants us to keep scanning for danger it
just we haven't evolved yet
to a place where we know that the actual
now
that's an obsolete tool that's scanning
for danger is actually the liability now
because it's making us anxious and tired
and distracted and
hurting our relationships and uh
eating away the collagen in our arteries
because we're producing so much cortisol
yeah and a lot of um it's like a
adaptive
behavior yeah and i think like um
with the craft legacy i like was
really interested a in getting in touch
with my inner child because it's a very
personal story to me and it's
it's a a young woman in adolescence
um like she moves into a house with
um with men for the first time basically
and i think there is that thing that
women continue to
um have to have to navigate which is
like
when is when is there when is that
danger something that we should listen
to
when is our gut something we should
listen to when it comes to that danger
as women in the world because especially
in adolescence we
sometimes before then you know
tragically for some
young women but in adolescence
especially we start to understand
ourselves as prey
like that's right and so for the first
time we're like we're also
sexually coming into our own so it's
like but there's no
real space for any sexual agency because
immediately we are also in danger and
men that we don't want to give us that
attention
are suddenly giving us attention that
feels really uncomfortable
um and so like i think even just that
like how that carries
through our lives as grown ass women is
like
how do you learn to trust you know in a
world where
you're initially when your brain is at
such an uh you know
um an important like stage of growth as
a young woman how do you like shift that
perception and should we because we
still are having to navigate
really gray areas all the time and like
that's why
my why me too was such a um powerful
and continues to be such a powerful
movement in that like suddenly it was
like
oh wait that wasn't allowed i thought
that was allowed
i was under i was under the impression
that that was love
or that that was that was a great date
or that that was a great date
you know um or that that was just uh and
any of those things right
it's just a relationship yeah yeah yeah
no it's because what
our age of p we normalized it and turned
so it's like
our incredible ability to adapt helped
us to cope
and normalize all that you know it's
like i mean i just went through this
with
the um you know people in my field
that continue to be exposed for their
behavior it's like everyone's like did
whitney knows like
well not only did i not see a lot of it
because they don't show it to me because
they wouldn't but also like
the putting your dick out and like i
just
i had to transmute that and alchemize
that into oh it's funny it's fine like i
had to
be desensitized to it and especially in
the world of comedy
but i would say in our industry anyway
yeah as a at large if i
stopped and had to or like stand up for
myself every time that happened that's
all i would do
that's all i would do and so to me it's
like the self-preservation was to
normalize it just ignore it
move on you know absolutely and it was
and you're
you're um rewarded for being able to
hang like the boys i'm cool yeah you're
a cool guy i eat wings
you can take it yeah and that's a
survival mechanism and that's what we
had to do to survive yeah absolutely and
the conditions are changing you know
and um and
um we jump around but the craft like
it's interesting because it's like
watching the version you made which
bench and i were trying to figure out a
way to like put words to it like we'll
just cry
but it was like i'm watching it i wrote
this is what i wrote down
the i felt nostalgic and seen and
understood and heard and celebrated
this movie is so confident these are the
notes i wrote on the plane
because this is someone that i when we
met you were
doing notes calls in the chair
on the movie that you had directed i had
uh
started written produced and started i
didn't direct it daryl directed it
that's right sorry sorry your husband
daryl
and um uh you're like on the f
like you had made another movie before
that uh called breaking up words
still the best title of any movie we'll
get to that at some point
uh this movie is like visual marzipan
i wrote that down amazing it is so
velvety
it's emotional velvet wow
i know that's wild you can have that for
the people thank you so much
the wardrobe set design is like the past
and future
all at once modern nostalgia
it's a luscious movie this is me on a
plane i mean there is some altitude
thrown in here
it's ancient and modern at the same time
wow is that the last note
wow wow um benton
is joining in on this conversation
because he
is how would you describe your
relationship to the craft i am
the it's the only thing that ever
mattered in my whole life
so i hope that's not any pressure
i'm thrilled what is the question i just
would like you to talk about your when
you first saw the craft
what happened to you what it did for you
i mean for me
i first saw the craft i was probably in
like the
fifth grade but i kind of like saw it
and like understood it
and for me it was a movie that
i mean i grew up in a really small town
as most of our listeners know like
really tiny like i think in lobeville
tennessee
in my fifth grade class there's probably
11 of us
and i already was like thought i was a
witch to begin with and then seeing that
movie i was like okay i
i understand these people like i can
relate to this and it was the only movie
i saw where like they were just like
weird and cool like they didn't care
that they were weird it wasn't like a
bad word and it wasn't masculine it
wasn't
it wasn't which i kind of yeah getting
into that part like when i saw the movie
i was like
okay well this is a bunch of women and
i'm always being told like
my feminine qualities are negative but
these are a bunch of really cool like
badass women
and then when i started to like look
into like the craft part of it i was
like oh like masculine and feminine
energies exist within this world like
this is a world where like
everyone has these energies and they're
like celebrated yeah and so i kind of
went with that and i was like okay well
this is now the world i live in
and i like i mean i really went with it
to the point where like i was dressing
like that
all the necklaces like my teachers were
spooked
you were like at the claire's kiosk
buying
chokers my mom would not go to claire's
my mom got me vintage chokers they were
very into it too
so i had vintage my mom got me a vintage
black
like um jacket that i wore and what is
which
will you just explain for like people
listening because if i'm listening i'm
going
what is witchcraft exactly i i
couldn't define it whitney cummings
doesn't know what it is i mean
i'm not a practicing witch so i don't
want to like be the spokesperson for
that
i'm not asking you to be but for me i
would say
i think that witchcraft is something
that everyone kind of has i think that
it's something that you
some people are probably more in tune
with it more innately like drawn to it
or something but i think it's
it's we have a long manifestation of
energy right it's just your energy you
being in power in in power
channeling the power you have that
you've kind of been like
been gasled into believing yeah i kind
of think which is like the first
feminist
in a way like they were they lived in a
world where they couldn't own property
or land they had no power and then all
of a sudden they're like well then
we're going to figure out a way to have
power and we're going to have so much
with it it scares you and then people
were so scared by it they had to start
killing them
yeah and they were also healers and they
were like community leaders they were
yeah and that was threatening right like
all of this is just like
establishment cannot deal with women who
are
either you know like in power or healing
communities
so let us vilify them and drown them and
burn them yeah and it was one of the
only it was really interesting to meet
you growing up reading out like the
history of witchcraft and stuff was that
it was one of the only spaces throughout
history where like
there wasn't this like male female
dynamic it was like the men
they were also called witches like they
were just as much a part of that
that mindset as the women were and it
was like this group of people who were
like living
as one kind of thought pattern instead
of like like men which is act like this
women which
they didn't have all that which was
really interesting to see
yeah absolutely and there's also like
such a um
like there's such a history of goddess
worship that's been
completely like erased from the history
books and that i think like
institutionalized religion like
definitely wanted to make
go bye-bye yeah but witchcraft is very
much about
no matter you know the gender of the
practitioner very much about like
getting back in touch with just the
divine feminine and how we pay
how we honor that energy both in
ourselves and to like a sort of a higher
power
and i think something i just feel the
need to say this like me charging
patriarchy i think
tends to trigger people because it's
it's they've become so like polluted
with like
um fake feminism who's that
did someone just come in who was that
is that mona hello
that's a ghost
you guys i think one of the salem
witches just wanted to join
why did my door just open and no one was
there
we're harnessing our fucking power
that was zoe's inner child just left the
building
it happened thank you so much we
couldn't see oh my god i feel so much
lighter
she's so short she doesn't want to
she zoe's in her child just excuse
herself
i'm not sensitive at all nobody has to
text me back
done i just i just fucking cracked it
tap your phone in half
um like me checking patriarchy because i
just feel like there's been a little bit
of this
like you know um bullshit like
mcdonald's feminism or whatever it is
that we're seeing on like twitter and
instagram that's kind of about like
superiority
and not equality you know i thought that
was one where you got a toy
this uh entitlement non-empowerment
there's a difference
and matriarchy doesn't mean
men aren't involved
valued loved matriarchy benefits
everybody
you know it's like i actually say like
it's the most alpha
and i know that word means nothing we
talk about this all the time i know i'm
using it wrong but let's just use the
traditional
archaic alpha the most alpha shit you
can do is let the women do all the work
that's what lions do lions are a
matriarchy the lion the male lion sleeps
20 hours a day
the women do the hunting the women do
all the rearing all the killing
and then the boys wake up to shit and
eat and fuck and they go back to sleep
it's not
bitch it's not you're not irrelevant
you're not obsolete
it's you don't lose power you know it's
like all the metrics of when you hire
more women your company becomes more
lucrative
it's actually the most selfish business
of people like you always hire so many
women it's like
that it's selfish well even beyond that
the interesting thing about like
the craft as like a practice is that
masculine and feminine exists in
everyone it's more about the divine
you're not living in a patriarch you're
making sure you're living in the divine
and we're not
um limiting ourselves with the
bifurcated like socially constructed
bifurcation of like you have to be this
or this or this
it's like take the best of both worlds
the masculinity the imaginative feminine
in all of us yeah and i think like one
thing that i did really want to explore
in the film which speaks to something
that you were just talking about is like
when you talk about the patriarchy like
the patriarchy and toxic masculinity
those things are hurting men that's like
that's that's it and i think that is the
thing that people
that's right that that people who ha uh
like
you know are triggered by those terms
especially men who are triggered by
those terms because they feel attacked
immediately by
them um i think like the thing that's
always missing and
this is true of any like social justice
movement of like
also for white people dealing with you
know like the ways in which we oppress
and how we can serve as allies
like if you understand the ways in which
that oppressive system is actually
causing you harm
then your allyship isn't as an outsider
so it's like it's like what
it's it's you know and i think the
pandemic and david o'yellow
oh and i talked about this when he was
here i know how to pronounce his name
that was just that was just the one time
i needed to take a breath
was during his name um
is the pandemic made us realize that
we're all connected
so it's like you know
being uh whatever institutionalized
racism
all that is like if someone's poor we're
all poor
yeah if someone's sick we're all sick so
helping other people
actually is selfish and benefits you you
know you're hurt
by that yes and and i think
um men feeling
um and we talked about this a little bit
before the podcast but like
men feeling that they that that
embracing their
divine feminine is shameful
is hurtful it's hurtful to men that's
not
so much masculinity is something you can
hide behind but i
i don't have it to hide anymore right
then what do i become but toxic
masculinity is a very like
like it means something different to
everybody it means something different
to everyone like i don't love that term
because it's a little bit if you're
triggered
it's too buzzy because you're bored but
here's here's how i'll put it
the number how many boys have been
molested in the catholic church
it's it's literally like almost in the
no one cares
no one talks about it no one covers it
it's too awkward to even talk about
like men are sexually appealing like no
one that's a great example of talking
about
yeah i'm not covering it because it's
weak for that to happen yes but i think
toxic masculinity like
has been sort of um advertisers used it
for razors or something so it just got a
little pop
it got a little mainstream pop and like
uh boulderized or something
but like no one so it's like men get
hurt and no one cares
you know because of all of this so it's
like well but i think like
i think that men get hurt and people
care
like in different ways like i think that
um
women and women of color get hurt and
nobody fucking cares in that way and
that now there's a moment
where finally yeah people are caring
yeah and there's a huge amount of
backlash yeah
because how dare any of these people who
should know their place yes well people
don't like things
actually stand up and try to shift a
really oppressive system that we're all
living under and can't even
see half the time so like i i do think
i think the way that men are are hurting
yes there is sexual abuse that is like
well because i think her vehicle
so you get hurt and then the only
solution to that hurt because you had no
power when you were hurt
is to now um uh subjugate other people
because you're subjugated so when we're
creating these invisible wounds
up till the age five these wounded
people grow up to be very dangerous
yeah yeah absolutely you ever had mad
dog 2020
no what's that it's like a real
hillbilly wine
it's like real rough that sounds amazing
it's it's not
trust me when i was little i was like
there's some on my dad's shelf and i was
like what is that what i kept asking you
like drink it
i threw it for a very long time well
that's because you didn't take the
bright cellars quiz
i should have took the breakfast twist
as a child you're right i should
i should have been a child here's my
deal with wine bright cellars
is a subscription service that helps you
find wines he'll love yeah that you love
and i'm not a wine person and this made
me a wine person well you're not a wine
person because you didn't know what
wines you liked because
how would you know i want wine to taste
like finding a needle and a needle stack
i want one to taste like um
a spicy juice and like this they gave
that to me
you take a quiz you go on there you take
it's a seven question quiz nobody go
through it they tell you what you like
because you don't know what you like
yeah it's impossible to know and they go
on a small date i don't know how taste
buds work
you go on a small date with them answer
a couple of questions
benton was giving me the bright cellars
wine quiz this morning
and i had a shift because i learned so
much about myself
asked me a couple of those questions we
both took this quiz it's really simple
what's one type of chocolate you do for
the rest of your life dark chocolate
milk chocolate
white chocolate type of chocolate i'd
eat for the rest of my life
why are you repeating the question no
that you're bringing up the fact that
i've dated black guys
reese's cup snickers or where's the
fruity candy
reese's they're gonna tell me what wine
i'm gonna like based on the answer these
are those maple leaf questions
what how do you like your tea iced and
sweet ice no sugar hot with sugar
arnold palmer brewed strong no tea no
tea
tea bagged it's not an option that's not
an option
arnold palmer tea bag i want him to
teabag
what's your go-to drink margarita beer
martini dry whiskey scotch mimosa
well i picked martini as well um nope uh
margarita
because you're trashy because i'm trying
what's your favorite
so so we did this quiz
and then they pick they send you wines
that you're gonna like based on that
quiz yeah here's the most important part
of this by the way these are also
questions you should ask
people on the first date this is the
most important part of that quiz is that
at the end of it they ask you how
adventurous are you and if you only want
to try
white wines only red wines if you want
to mix if you want mostly red mostly
white
that's important because i mostly wanted
white wines and i tried
just some red they take the hassle out
of shopping for wines
also give me those what those cards
these are really important oh they send
you little cards
and they have they tell you what
temperature to put the wine in your like
to chill out they tell you all the
flavor notes in there
they tell you what it pairs best words
like it tells you what
food it pairs best with it it tells you
where it is
you nailed it what region it's from they
tell you and then you get to rate it in
this company
you get you get to rate it on here with
these little stars which i do
they sent me my favorite part of wine is
the label and they know that i love
crickets
when i'm bombing when my jokes are
bombing this is symbolic it has crickets
on it
but you feel like it's a car and then
the next time you go into order
you give them the results back from the
wines you chose
i mean is that just this wine bottle
they sent me is just me
oh this is mine huh that's yours happy
medium wine i should have that one
what um wow this is really important you
keep talking over it
so you fill this little card out you
check the stars when you go back to get
your next box you tell them how much you
like these
and they even that one's really good i
had that one um
they narrow it down even more so every
box it gets more and more specific to
what you're gonna love
you guys it happened i'm holding a
bottle of white wine i've turned it on
my mother
for good for you listeners only we are
giving you 50 off your first six bottle
orders from
bright sellers by going to
brightsellers.com good for you that's
bright sellers
c-e-l-l-a-r-s dot com slash good for you
you can take their seven
question quiz and get your wine matches
and receive 50
off your first six bottle order
it's so wild to me the number of people
i know that are
haunted by student loans and how they
are shackled by
just it's like um what's the thing that
followed them around in christmas
the ghost of christmas past with the
chains that's what it
makes me imagine your student loans are
following you
they are i dated a guy who used me gold
digged me
to help him pay his student loans that's
an entrepreneur
he uh we dated for a little while he
would
come home at four in the morning because
he was working as a caterer
and you know how much i value my sleep
and he'd come home at four in the
morning
and wake me up and i was like i don't
think this is gonna work
because you're interrupting my sleep and
he was like well i'm doing this to pay
my student loans and i was like okay
can i help you i emasculated him
and asked that but he said yes which is
a testament to how desperate
people who owe money to colleges feel
and i was like okay let me just pay your
student loans this month
it was like thirty five hundred dollars
that's cheap
they're low they mean you take out like
it's like 30 you can take out like
30 000 or more per semester
and then you think you're like i'll pay
all this back with my job i get after
college criminal i've never thought
about this before and then you have to
use the money to live off of it you have
to use that money you have to use your
school loan money to pay the interest
back off on the school loan you have
while you're in school still
do you have an elegant segue into yeah
this is this is about earnest
ernest i'm i'm so glad this company
exists because i don't know what people
were doing before earnest
they help you figure out how in the sam
hell
to pay off your student loans yeah
before earnings it's a rubik's cube of a
nightmare
before earnest you were just dodging
phone calls and waiting for way to win
the lottery
you're just getting stalked by debt
collectors and posting your
only fans earnest is the easiest way to
refinance your student loan saving you
time and money
you can even check your rate you
complete a few questions online
it takes like two minutes calm down well
depending on your wi-fi connection it
should take about two minutes
you'll get a personalized rate estimate
without affecting your credit score
that's important because your credit
scores are already affected by the loan
once i didn't know that when you check
things like that it affect your credit
score
not with earnest you can even combine
private and federal loans
you would have one single monthly
payment the fact that they don't already
do that is crazy
it is crazy ernest is bringing sanity
into
a very insane nightmare
if you've already refinanced that's
totally fine you can still be eligible
to lower your interest rate again our
listeners are gonna get a 100
cash bonus when you refinance a student
loan at earnest.com
whitney that's a hundred dollars hundred
dollars that's
not a joke cash bonus when you refinance
a student loan at earnest.com
whitney go to earnest.com whitney today
terms and conditions apply
the boxes that men feel they have to be
confined within
are so limiting that they limit i mean
they limit
men emotionally so much that there isn't
space for vulnerability i remember
like what we were kind of talking about
for like the original craft is something
when you watch it
because it one of the time period it
came out and it was also very limited
roles that women could play
they know that yeah you wanted to relate
to that movie like like as an lgbtq
person or as uh
many types of people you had to search
for yourself in that movie and in the
retelling that you did
there's no searching there's you are in
that movie there yeah if you exist
you're in that movie somewhere also the
original and you don't have to work so
much
there's no there's not so much figuring
it out like i know that i'm in that
movie and i can watch it and gain from
it
as opposed to having to create that side
guys for myself
the original craft had actresses that
looked
different than the actresses we had seen
mm-hmm
it was one of the only movies that
touched on suicide and rape
and racism at the time yeah it was very
hard one of the storylines is literally
a
racism a whole storyline yeah right yeah
and then so what happened when you saw
it
for for me well i mean for me it was
really cool because you know i have
mom my mom's hi my family is they're
mixed those i
saw people that look like like uh like
rochelle in the movie
and so it was really interesting to see
that and then i had something to play
with my cousins you know
and then what do you mean you were able
to watch the movie we were able to watch
the movie
yeah we were able to watch it but then
like as kids we were to like play
witches together now there was no other
movie that they that they had that
showed so you're black
relatives all of a sudden now you had
something you could do together yeah for
you know that and then also for me like
i
i had never experienced someone being
mean to me in that way the way that she
was being picked on in that movie
and i was like you know because to me
like i saw them you know all getting
like
you know hot cums ran through their hair
and getting their hair braided so like
that wasn't weird to me
yeah and just and to see that it was
weird in this movie i was like i don't
understand what
what what's the hair thing i didn't yeah
so my mom had to explain to me like well
here's why she's being bullied in this
movie for her hair like i didn't get
that as a kid
someone had to tell me it was the first
time i saw that and then just see
someone
uh you know like and then there was you
know and then you had bonnie who had
scars and stuff
and like my dad is handicapped so seeing
a character who was like
who was you know i had an affliction
that was like physical was really
interesting to me i never really related
to sarah but i really related to nancy
as this person who like
wasn't like you know she grew up in like
a trailer park that's what i was
surrounded by was like trailer parks and
i was like that's what i felt like so i
felt like nancy watching that movie
which is point out the best takeaway but
um seeing how the movie ends and
everything but like that's what i feel
like i was like oh look at this person
who's like weird and different and does
not
care yeah doesn't care like that and
like built a friend group
like give you permission to build a
friend group that was like diverse yeah
i think that movie did maybe i was like
oh i can have friends that are all kinds
of
i mean i did take a little too far
because i am in my head i was living in
the movie
so like when people come to my school
like in eighth grade i mean i hear this
movie all
throughout life in eighth grade we had a
new yeah no shit who is my friend uh
she's still my friend of the day kayla
and uh she showed up and the first thing
i said to her is are you one of us
yeah like a psycho like a psycho like
the opening scene i was like prepared to
see like people chanting when candles
and you redid it in a way where it was
like these are kids that live right now
they're living in today's world
they have the internet they found this
on the internet they didn't go to a
store that's right
they're like fumbling around having a
good time like they were you know it's
the perfect amount of nostalgia but also
moderate
i got to connect to a movie but see a
new story and that's what i want out of
out of like a retelling i want to
experience something new
and i thought you did that in a way
where not only could i i didn't have to
look for myself in the movie i have to
search for a character that
well what is is this character like me
it's every character is there there's
i mean you have trans characters you
have people who are coming out you have
moms dads
masculine figures feminine figures you
have also
sorry can i get into the genius of the
choices
like michelle monahan mostly known
uh for a movie called maid of honor
which i was in
i played her bridesmaid in maid of honor
nominated for a few oscars right uh
two couple razzies yeah i get those two
things
honestly same death um and
uh uh true detective i mean she's just
impossible she was incredible she's
michelle like talk about a woman who
like
first of all she's the most like down to
for whatever person in the coolest way
that is everything that is
that i am not yeah like she's like
she is just like she's just a scratchy
bitch
yeah she's scrappy she's cool she eats
like a trucker
she's going to start burning oh no she
wouldn't like oh we would get wasted
on i don't i didn't i was full of virgo
like yeah we would uh doing the movie
made of honor she's starring in a movie
like doing shots at midnight
before a 5 a.m call she is everything i
wish i could be
yes and then also on top of that the
most
gracious yeah generous classy loving
present and the way that she has not
only supported this film but supported
me
and the young women in this film like
every wednesday she does a woman crush
wednesday and showcases one of the coven
members like on her instagram
just like she's just beautiful and
giving she is a real one
love her so much um and then the casting
of the girls i mean it was
i guess i just it's very rare that i
watch a movie and i'm like
like i'm hooked like i'm usually just
watching a movie and
you know i say a lot the reason
comedians are so depressed is we lost
the ability to watch comedy the one
thing we all use to investigate
ourselves
all we're doing is watching and going i
wish i thought of that why does he have
it and i don't why does she have it and
i don't it's like we can't enjoy comedy
uh it's hard to enjoy movies because all
i'm doing is going i auditioned for that
i didn't get that i wish i had gotten
that
uh i don't buy it that's adr like just
the inner monologue of being like okay
like that was a re-shoot yeah continuity
oh shoot that's all you're thinking
right virgo and um this was like i was
and i know you i like i know you we i
saw you after the movie wrapped we got
our nails done like i knew it was a
movie more than
kind of any movie i've ever seen i knew
it was a movie
and i was still able to surrender
my brain was still still able to
surrender with it oh i knew none of that
and didn't know you
and i surrendered to it and it was a
much tougher critic than whitney was
i will say like like i legit like even
down to i was like is she going to copy
their clothes from the 90s and then you
did these little touches of like plaid
pants instead of like schoolgirl
uniforms
and you like oh don't get me started on
the copper i do like a funeral
weaved in these like quotes from the
original movie that you would had to be
a die-hard fan of to even know that was
from the original movie and they were in
these places where you were like
like i would catch them and i'd be like
look at that and it was such like a
respectful way to pay homage to
something without showing the same story
that i was like
oh i'm totally on board with this for
you to put in these little tiny
moments was like so impressive to me i
was like oh wow like
and not only that but the detail and
like the you could tell that there that
you like
research witchcraft and stuff down to
like using bodily fluids and the period
and all these moments always and it's
interesting because this maybe have a
flashback
to you know i used to be incredibly
like jealous of you that's not true yes
it is
because zoe has um many things i don't
have
um but you have an uh a
knack is so such an insulting way to
phrase it
but your um
aesthetic your fashion sense do you
remember the time that i used to buy
clothes
just because i thought you'd wear them i
showed up one time on the set of whitney
in a
beige leather coat with zippers and she
and i love that and i went i bought it
because i thought you'd like it
and you were like no you literally went
like you literally
it was just like this single white
female moment you're like i love that i
was like i know that's why i bought it
so for a long time like when i used to
care about clothes
i would just when i thought that was
going to fix the invisible wounds
shopping i would buy it doesn't it
it doesn't work plot twists
i love how you're seeing this interview
and this movie through the lens of
knowing her and i'm seeing it through
something i know
but your relationship to this original
movie is my relationship to her right so
it's like we have the inverse
relationship it's
wild yeah so that movie is zoe to you
and though he is right right the craft
so um but
your it's because i always say the most
important
um person on a movie in a way is the
costume designer because it's the first
thing you see
before anything else it's the first it's
the
to me because it's like the right the
costume designer the writer and the co
it's like you're the costume designers
are writers
i mean they are because they decide what
you
the impact the first thing you see the
first visual
of tells the story of this person the
shirt tells the story the makeup tells a
story so
they're writers and your um acumen
for costume is so
uh potent in this movie
well i mean even getting thank you super
granular did the costume designer hate
you
no and i have to give her a shout out
sorry to interrupt you but um
her name is avery plus and she is
brilliant and
the collaboration was such a dream which
it could have gone terribly right
but i got you but then i want to talk
she got me because now i want to talk
about your interviewing process of how
you hire people because when you're
directing a movie and it's your
vision you need people that can
anticipate your needs
not take uh uh
direction as criticism right
and i want to talk about your um
experience as being a young beautiful
female boss
and what happens and how you hire people
yeah because you were taking on a lot i
mean you were having to go you were
having to like
you have to fire reimagine yeah so what
happens
and a story that is like burnt into
places let's talk about the nasty
heart now let's get away from the
lotting and let's try
i love the lotting part i like to sit
here for a little bit
a little bit longer what else did you
like about it um
failures so um uh
how do you fire people i couldn't do it
well i don't think i've ever fired
someone i just keep them on because i
was too afraid of the discomfort well
i'm deeply codependent yeah
and um also which codependent on this
show we divine
define as the inability to tolerate the
discomfort of others
that's yeah exactly right and also um
which is interesting the irony of that
um
is that when one person is the rotten
apple
the other if there's 200 people in the
crew the other 199 people
are uncomfortable yes so we can't we
tolerate that discomfort
and our discomfort not the person who's
the problem absolutely and on a film set
it is or tv set um it is uh
i i like always talk about the beauty of
it is that you have
a huge group of people operating as one
living organism
right like in terms of anticipating
needs and everyone coming which every
job in some way whether you work with
yeah or whether it's whatever your job
is the same so
i just like to frame that because i
think a lot of times people talk about
the movie business in hollywood as if
it's so different from every other
business but it's just
so no every business is about
the collective like and if that
collective is running smoothly then your
business is running smoothly um but it's
ultimately we're all five years old and
running around with egos and fears
and when you're the boss you're
everyone's uh you have the negative
qualities of everyone's primary
caretaker so you're mama
dada yeah so people just picked to you
yes so that is uh difficult i think like
part of the hiring process for me
is um i like to meet as many people as i
can in person like even down the line
um just because like just to get a sense
of people's energies like because like
you said if there's
one rotten apple that is going to impact
the entire but let me ask you
well i think what i learned was it's not
about their energy
it's about your energy when you're with
them do you feel pressured to perform
do you feel pressure to compliment them
do you feel pressured to be unctuous
like i
find like when you walked in the room
uh when i first met you when you
auditioned for the show it was like
i have to do nothing right yeah and
that's how you really i don't know
how are you so it was like every other
actress that came in for your part
slash job it was like hi how are you
you're so great anyway so we're going to
read the scene yeah here's the direction
it was like you came in and i had to do
nothing
yes because we're still in that way
energy yeah that that's the right
fit yes so i made the mistake
uh the first season of the show we
worked on second season and pretty much
um i've made this mistake a lot of
someone comes in and
i go how am i gonna love you and i
shapeshift because i know how to
do that i grew up walking on eggshells
narcissist so i know how to shape shift
uh to make us have good chemistry and i
do all the work
and then i go oh we had such good
chemistry and then i hired them
but i'm doing all the work yes yes
yeah instead of allowing myself to do
nothing and vibrate the right person
it's not about right romantic
relationships leaning out
leaning out so my next painting
will be lean out the opposite of lean in
lean out let everyone else lean in make
fools of themselves
embarrass themselves uh where you just
limbo your way past problems
you're going to lean out collect
information that's right
and then you're going to come in with
the mic dropper at the end that's right
yeah you're going to pop up like one of
those clowns out of a box
with the answer no you're gonna be like
one of the um
uh those things at a car dealership the
balloons that come off that's you
and back down yeah something to say with
the answer
give me the back yes because if you
speak first you're giving away all your
power
right true power doesn't have to
advertise itself and i think that does
that sort of like
is your you just answered your own
question in terms of what i try to do is
like
[Laughter]
so i don't need thank you so much this
has been fun
back and forth her dream
literal dream interview herself you just
answered your own
questions but on the topic of power
because this is something in the movie
that i notice
is how conscious was it for you to put
these
uh the the witches the girls the women
in this movie in a situation where they
are
very aware of having power and just
needing to figure out a way to channel
it
as opposed to the original one where it
was like this group of girls who were
like oh my gosh we have powers
and then they're almost getting like
addicted to them and they're like
like how are we going to use them your
girls seem to live in a world where it's
20 20.
we have the internet we know that we're
strong but now what how are we going to
use this power
was that like a conscious choice yeah i
think it was i mean i
i i knew that from the jump
i wanted this to be a story of young
women whose power didn't overwhelm them
to the point of um
disabling them and i think like that's
been the narrative that so many of us
have witnessed in popular culture when
young women get power especially young
witches
that it then they they become over uh
out of control yes man name a girl it's
out of control
and then they'll turn it on each other
and this for me was
such an amazing opportunity to tell a
different story which is that
these are young women who understand
their powers who who
um embody their powers and that power i
think the the bigger lesson is that
that power is at its greatest height
when they are in community
rather than in you know rather than
individuals well that's the thing right
now what i want to talk about no but i
want to talk about this because
to me i was conditioned to compete with
women
i was conditioned to believe that
another woman women
woman winning means i lose yeah
if she succeeds i because there's only
one seat
there's one seat at the table and there
was for so long and
the scarcity complex of if there's one
other female comic on the line it's me
or her it's me or you
you're my nemesis we know
you want to fade into the camera i'm
saying i i
didn't you know i think women were like
i don't think we've caught up on this
yet
like i think no but you did that's what
that's what i'm saying these girls knew
girls now know
i i think this next generation knows
because they saw
it's like uh who saw how we fucked up
that was so smart i thought it was so
clever no we didn't know what
to do we
coped we did what we had to do to get by
we did the best we
can with the tools and the circumstances
we had but i think it's like who was it
that said um
i'm plagiarizing somebody
um i got it annie letterman um
uh boys will be boys but girls will be
girls so that's what happened with
uh me too it's like yeah we're gonna
talk like you know what i mean you know
we're gossiping we talk and we compare
notes like girls will be girls you
forgot that
so it was like i think women were like
oh we are we
don't have to we're not against each
other we're more powerful together and
it's taken me
i mean it's really taken me
until the i mean in the last year is
really the
really when i sort of like was able to
not see the success of other women as a
threat to me
but you should give yourself more credit
because you
like as we as we talked about the
beginning of this podcast i mean in a
primal way in a primal way i totally
feel
like you also have you see the
incredibly supportive you see i have
because that's consciously who i am but
i'm talking about maybe like the
split second reaction of when i see that
another woman
has gotten something that i want that uh
when your heart takes a shit in your
chest that little pit yeah
but that's really cool it's a pr it's a
primordial reaction it's a it's
a i'm not gonna eat it's a you think
you're gonna yeah you i don't have the
protection of the tribe you should be
able to
think that though i i know that's what
i'm saying by i think it's biology i
think it's also
but it's it's taken a long time your
brains we need a lot of proof my brain
needs a lot of
proof and she's shining and i'm not
i'm not shining because i think that's
the other thing is that like
i need to shine and be um
the addict brain and the of the
constitutional need to be special
if she's special i can't be special i
mean it's it's really um
it's really it's really fucking deep
it's really deep and it's not and it's
really hard
to um avoid because of the conditioning
but i will say that like in my life and
i think probably
similar in yours although you know
you've had some complicated
relationships um
in that arena but like seeing the gifts
that other women can give as mentors
or even just as support systems is like
such a great
it just like it does rewire a little bit
where you're like that just
um uplifted me and nourished me in such
a deep way i want to also do that
but it doesn't change that first
instinct of like there's only room for
one yeah
which is so fucked up and it's also not
you know
it's interesting because it's like um i
know this is like a hot take but it's
not like
all women you know like i had this
really tricky conversation with
a younger female comic who was like i
can't believe there's not more female
comedians on the main room lineup and i
was like
who and it was like okay well allie wong
and and
they're all selling out theaters they're
busy that's why they're not here
they're not here because they're rich
and successful i mean they're all
touring so that's not a conspiracy
that's not a sexist conspiracy they're
off being rich and talented
and allie was like making her movie or
whatever and then
there was well this girl this girl in
this girl but they've only been doing
this for two years right so they don't
deserve to be here
right they don't get in a spot they
don't deserve because they're women so
that's equality it's the same everything
you know it's like granted there was
like uh
you know we didn't get the head start
but it's like
that to me like i was put in the
situation where they were like well you
need to fight for these
women to get this spot on the lineup i'm
like i'm not going to fight for them to
get something that they don't deserve
yet
that's not kind to them right and you
had to pay your dues and so you you know
and i think i guess the question is
because i'll fight for them for the
chance to pay their dues that's correct
that's correct and that's what you said
that's correct because i went if this
the worst thing i can do for this girl
is get her a spot before she's ready and
now i'm not gonna serve her yeah women
aren't funny now
yeah i was seen too soon i got i got
too much exposure before i was ready
everything happens it's actually as it
should it's fine
but i kind of got something that i
didn't deserve in the beginning like my
first late night set like last call with
carson daly i'd been doing stand for
like five months
and they needed a woman they literally
just needed a woman and i
i wasn't ready yet i mean it was last
call with carson daly so i was probably
too funny for them but like you know
and you know i think it's just until
recently that female director female
comedian
one doesn't represent all like i think
true equality is like this is what we're
talking about with david oh yellow is
like
the freedom to be bad at something and
not set back everyone
yeah that was such a great interview
yeah like like the freedom to be
mediocre
and i think that as women especially i
think everyone is plagued by this but i
think
um as women and and people of color and
anyone who there are barriers to entry
um you know lgbtq communities community
or men sure southern men yes anywhere
there are barriers to entry
there is um such a
um
i guess there's like we we are there's a
need to prove ourselves so that we won't
actually
try something until we know we're
perfect at it which i know is sort of
contradictory what you're saying no no
no no no no no no no act as if no i'm
also hypocrite because also act as if
that there is something to like i had
never
i had never directed a studio film i had
never directed a film that required vfx
that required stunts that required
special effects
like there were many reasons why i could
have said
i'm not ready but i was also like
i am ready but you already have the
power and you just needed the covenant
yes that's right i need that but that is
part of one of them
but i will say and that's know know what
you can figure out later
because in movies you can fit you can go
i'll figure this out i'll and
you know and knowing how to ask for help
and that is part of it too which is that
i stand up you have one shot and it's
live and i think for
for women especially in our industry
um when you are as you know directing
um or running a show or anything um
there are so many it's really hard to
allow yourself to ask for help because
you want everyone to
really believe that you deserve to be
there and that you can do everything and
that you can do everything yourself and
i
uh gave myself permission to to be like
what does that mean
you know because there's a lot of things
like in the vfx world i'm like sorry
what does that term mean
and it was so hard for me especially as
a virgo and as a perfectionist to ask
those questions which is so ironic
because
ironic um it's i know it's like the
hackiest word and i'm probably misusing
it but that's fine
um elena's more status featured have
movies i feel like it's appropriate
to say ironically it's a real tie-in um
it's it's so
odd that we're afraid to ask uh
a question about what something is
because the only people i trust are the
ones that admit they don't know
something yes
as soon as someone says i don't know
what this means i go
whoa now i can trust when you say you do
know what things absolutely when someone
knows everything i assume they know
nothing
yeah and that is part of the smartest
people ask
questions questions and and that is part
of i think like
running went back to the question that i
said that you answered
i'm going to answer it again um and i'm
going to do it better i'm going to do it
i'm going to do my side of the interview
[Laughter]
no i was just going gonna say that like
i think part of like um
what i learned in watching directors
that i really respect
is that it is such a like um
it is about the collective so much right
it is about it's about
creating space and holding space for the
people that you've
trusted with your vision to actually
have their own visions too
like if if you are so narrowly focused
on it's
like mind mind mind mind why did you
hire me if you don't want my ideas
absolutely and you're the best person
and that's what it is yeah and that's
when it creates resentment and that's
when those relationships go awry
it's not i'm hiring you to be a puppet
and i'm the marionette doll app no i'm
if you're not hiring someone for their
if you're micromanaging someone you hire
the wrong person
then will you do your um joke about good
hire
oh about yeah pension it's such
jobs they just hire whoever like you'll
come in like they can't open their
locker and you're like good hire
it's just good hire it's just
because that's your new merch because
benjamin is so high functioning like
imagining
you at working at sephora or or
aeropostale i was a monster american
eagle american people
whatever was always wrong i was like
what's wrong with everyone here
is so brilliant my favorite i don't
think we've told the story on the big
ass
where um people the way that women steal
from sephora
is that they oh all people not just
women i'm sorry
i'm sorry sorry i'm sexist um the way
that uh they steal lipstick from sephora
is that they um
they will twist up the texture lipstick
bite it off and hold it in their mouth
and walk out
yeah or like around holiday when
everything's traveling they'll just
that's the original super spreader
benton face that way more
maybe it out maybe oh i'm just trying to
brilliant
i know more but i need you to be engaged
i need and then also um
the way a woman bought lemaire and then
no she oh my god she bought mac
we mac a studio cream uh-huh it's a
really heavy heavy thick moisturizer
she would come back and return them full
of mayonnaise and and one day
we had like uh this like kick-ass
manager
her name was shia she's this awesome
black one she's a great artist and she
she snatched that on her and she went
this is mayonnaise and handed it back to
her just a smash she just knew exactly
this is mayonnaise it's like folklore
people are
wild zing mayonnaise though probably
wouldn't be bad for the skin
but you could smell it because it's like
is that like a plumping it just seems
gross
okay um you're probably right but i i
just
love i love your energy with a bunch of
um
incompetent people it's so funny to me
yeah i'm always very confused but you
have to hire who will take the job
what happens um when you uh what
happened
when you when your town thought you were
a witch they held a town hall meeting
that they invited my parents to and i
had to sit in the car because i was
spooky
why were you why did your town think you
were a witch
because i was i mean they weren't wrong
i was doing everything in my power to
make you think that
because then when i watched the movie i
was like oh this is how you get people
to leave you alone you just spook them
yeah
and then it worked too good um i started
giving out books to other kids their
parents did not like it
what kind of book craft butchcraft books
i was like you want to read this book
about a spell
are we starting a group is this a group
thing i need friends and they didn't
like it and they had to have a meeting
about it and they just have all of our
meetings at town hall because it's such
a small town it's like
that's just where you go it sounds very
dramatic yeah but i mean that was where
it was uh-huh
my parents went and they got into a lot
of deep stuff i wear crystals he dresses
in all black
all very trendy nowadays ahead of your
time
yeah so who held the town hall meeting
uh
two teachers and a mayor the mayor
well who has to be there to open the
house the mayor got involved
that's how spooky you are because that's
what they well they all went to the same
church
my town is just churches and hairstyles
and then you sat in there
yeah church's hair salons and we have a
sonic now
a couple miles away
[Music]
[Laughter]
i had to sit in the truck which seems a
little rude considering everybody else
could go in there but i couldn't
i think they thought it was to like it
felt like they were scared but it seemed
like what they're i think they didn't
want
the kid to hear as if i wouldn't know
while we were at the meeting like my
parents
weren't going to get in the car and be
like can you maybe i don't know eat
lunch with
maybe lunch with a youth pastor for a
month and a half
at a public school might not have
lunches i would sit there and he would
tell me why my marilyn manson shirt was
evil why
he would tell me how the osbournes were
evil me and my mom loved the tv show the
osborne
people watch it really and they weren't
into it
um and basically it was a lot of that
they sung a lot to me on a guitar they
would play an acoustic guitar so they
were trying to convert you back to
a human from which i don't know i guess
they thought that i was spooky and ooky
and kooky but i was just
i mean i was like okay what my parents
were literally my parents got back in
the car and they went
you're gonna have to eat with the eat
your food and then they went just be
nice to him
that's all they told me he's buying you
chokers my mom and my dad my dad
was so full into it he was like he was
like what book should we get next what
do you want to read next
that's amazing my dad was like it's
history but it's like that's all history
um he was like all that stuff people
believe that stuff at one point in time
he was like might as well read about it
figure out why
and then my mom was just any any excuse
my mom could put me in a costume she was
all down for
is there something making you less happy
in life
is there something preventing you from
achieving your goals don't say yourself
is there something really messing up
your day
do you cry a whole lot crying is healthy
you know where i learned that therapy
crying is like is releasing i used to
think my therapist explained to me like
crying
is releasing old pain it doesn't mean
you failed it doesn't mean you're a bad
person it's information and she also
explained to me that because men are so
bad at reading faces
that women evolve to cry when they were
in pain
so that men would know they were in pain
weird not wild i cry and use the tears
to wash my face
i just rehydrate myself i just put a
little dollop of face wash i cry a lot
rub it in
i just think the key to sanity i mean
you've noticed
i i've i've hit a new gear in the last
week
you have all my the therapy i've been
doing for the past 10 years has just
like
clicked everything clicked
do you know what i'm saying all the work
you do on yourself pays off it might not
pay off
right this second all your puzzle pieces
fell into place they really did
you can see the whole picture so i've
been going therapy for
so long and i never knew if it was
working
do you know what i mean like i never
knew it's not like you go to therapy
once and it's over
that's not how it works you kept being
like why do people keep leaving
and it all kind of um
starts to crystallize over time and then
as your outlook gets more positive and
as you start like
sort of seeing yourself differently you
start seeing the world differently and
then everything just starts to get
better
help better help well that's
motivational i feel
lucky that we are alive at a time where
we can have therapy online how lucky are
we
that's pretty cool i mean betterhelp can
help you start communicating in under 48
hours although it's not a crisis line
it's not self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online that's
important because my therapist for the
longest time told me
that she wouldn't take insurance because
she didn't want my insurance company to
know
that i had mental health problems you
don't want that to make your insurance
go up or
what if that date is available later at
some point
yeah do you know what i mean and how
would people ever know with you having a
podcast talking about it all the time
thank god she didn't take that payment
wouldn't it be terrible if i wrote a
book about this and saved money
you can log into your account
[Music]
so i just wrote a book about it yeah
she's like you you get on stage every
night and talk about your mental issues
i don't want to take that insurance you
can pay full price
because i went to therapy i was able to
manifest you benton
benton is a product of my therapy this
whole all my success i rubbed a lamp and
all of my success is because i went to
therapy and
got out of my own way and you guys can
go too get out of your own way
with better help it's committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
they make it easy and free to change
counselors if needed it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling because you're not paying for
the office of the therapist you're not
paying for something yeah you're not
paying for their birken bag
better health wants you to start living
a happier life today
visit their website and read their
testimonials they're posted daily
visit betterhelp.com whitney that's
better help
h-e-l-p and join the over one million
people taking charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional
in fact so many people have been using
better help that they're recruiting
additional counselors in
all 50 states special offer for good for
you listeners
get 10 percent off your first month at
better help slash whitney
hold your whoop up i'm going to resist
the urge to sing whoop there it is
i'm going to remember this
you know that do you know that song yes
of course i do really i had middle
school dances
so you guys know whoop
joe rogan talks about it all the time i
wore my whoop band on joe rogan
and he didn't notice i was i wore it
because i wanted to impress him you were
just sitting like this
i was i was whole i was
look at me i'm an elite performer i
literally
wore my woot band on joe rogan to try
to get his followers to like me more
and it actually worked i got the least
negative comments
on my last joe rogan appearance when i
had a woop band on i feel like
that's why they thought you were a dead
lifter they were like oh she gets it i
were mine when we were performing
and i was stunned at my heart rate
really
it told you your heart rate when you
were performing on stage why you wear it
all the time so tells you all the time
and i know but when i got off it was
like it was like
you exercised it thought i was
exercising i had to go in the journal
entry and be like i wasn't exercising
that's how hard you work on stage when
you're performing that's fascinating
because
um we were having a conversation about
whoop where
we can read the copy you guys can google
what woop is you know what it is i don't
want to bore you with the copy but i had
an epiphany this morning about
wearing the woof band because what it
does is it basically
tells you how you're sleeping what your
this is what i'm focusing on the quality
of your sleep and
it made me realize that i have a false
narrative about myself
and that i have like man i have
written a story about myself that's not
true and cast myself in a role
that is now obsolete uh and that's
and it helped me delete a story about
myself that's no longer serving me
because my whole thing about myself is i
don't sleep enough i'm always tired i
didn't get enough sleep i can't sleep i
can't fall asleep
that's my whole thing about myself but i
nap i go to bed early i looked at the
whoop band
and it gives you a score proof i love
proof you know i love proof it tells you
when you're awake
i love true science i woke up and it
said you had a hundred percent
sleep quality and it told me how like
how much rem sleep i got
how much when you're light sleeping and
it made me realize that
my perception of myself is wrong and
that i have bad pr about myself
this is a powerful thing benton yeah i
had a similar experience because
i'm like that blew my mind and then i
went oh
and it made me have more energy because
i stopped
living in this fictitious world of like
i can't sleep i'm always tired
no i'm not the whoop band told me that
i'm not tired
haven't you i have so much more energy
now it's like band is your god
it kind kind of it's been like a
wild shift i had a similar experience
because i always feel like i'm not doing
anything ever like i'm never burning
calories and the whoop band is like but
you you're like yes you are
all these so it's you said it this
morning and i was like oh if i take the
stairs that did make a difference
it's like a friend and a coach and a
scientist and a cheerleader yeah it's
all the things
and a trainer all in one place in a
journal
like it's just it's just so fat and then
we just have it right here on our wrist
it tells you everything you need you
wear it all the time it's waterproof you
never take it off and the charger you
put the charger on and wear the charger
until you're done with it
it never comes off your body it's truly
magic
right it's magical yeah it's it's a no
it's like
you can't not have it it's the truth and
you can't have it it solves
so many of my problems i don't spend the
whole day
wondering how i slept also with my
workout sometimes i work out and you
know you're leaving you're like i don't
know if that was a good workout i'm not
sure and then you spend all this mental
energy being like
was that a good word the loop bands like
it wasn't the whoop band will just tell
you straight up facts
the whoop band is like i've just i feel
like it's like
a part of my brain like but it's just
here's the thing the whoop band is never
it's really good about like say your
workout wasn't the best that day it's
like oh that's because
yesterday you worked so hard you didn't
sleep well
or you didn't sleepo or you didn't do or
you did a bomb workout today you need to
sleep more tonight
you know what i'm going to tell you when
to go to sleep it bosses you around it's
like your dom personal dominatrix
and you can have one because loop is
offering 50 off right now with the code
whitney at checkout
go to whoop wh oop dot com and enter
whitney at checkout to say 15
sleep better recover faster and train
smarter optimize your performance with
woop today
honestly get your shit together you
thought of that name you know what whoop
help me get my shit together mentally it
whooped you into shape
so this is interesting because i
remember um
your approach when you're directing
actors and when you're the boss of 200
people
whether you're a boss of two people five
people you're whatever this is all
um relates to everyone i watched
something christopher
nolan said once i once just googled
speaking of
doing something you're not ready for um
when i quote directed a movie
um come on i i saw christopher nolan
said something which is just such a
great like just lesson on human nature
in general he was like the thing about
actors
we treat them like children in which i
have plenty of
notes on celebrities and actors sure it
uh
we treat them like children they are in
a lot of ways that's what we want actors
to be we want them to be open and
playful and in their in their play brain
with their frontal lobes shut down we
want them to
be you know with no fear and childlike
and impis in a lot of ways
but you can't lie to actors they're
actors they're students of human
behavior and emotion
and when we lie to someone they know
something's off
and then they just stop trusting you
mm-hmm and christopher nolan's like it's
my job to be in charge
so i have to tell them when something
goes wrong and like
like i've been in a lot of situation
work where they're like oh we're gonna
shoot over here and you're like why and
they're like oh just because i think
this is better and you're like
okay and you don't totally believe them
like no one's getting away with anything
i believe yeah when you're around
emotionally intelligent people that
um we can pretend we get it but we
really don't you stop trusting the
person and you
you know they don't know why you don't
really know why because they sold it
but so he learned to go
uh we're losing light here because we
took too long you admit
all the things that went wrong you admit
it because
and then they feel safe it's anathema to
i think
the instinct to protect yourself and
pretend you're good at everything
you go i messed up on the last scene and
we lost light
so now we're going to shoot here which
is my second choice
but i'll fix it and post and it'll be
fine and they go great
well i think so many uh actors also want
to be directors like
you know or or are interested or have
been on enough sets where they
understand the nature of production
that i think letting them in on the
nature of the production is always
helpful whether or not it's your fault
you know just being like we're going to
shoot this because or we need to go
again
yeah or we need to go again because
there was a technical issue it wasn't
on you yeah you know what i mean or any
of those things because i think
when actors are kept in the dark yes
then they start to
panic her field and i think this is the
same with parenting children people want
to lie to their children and they want
to go like
no mommy and daddy you're fine no we
were just yeah yeah yeah no we were
fighting we had a disagreement yeah and
kids go
yeah a god they can handle we're getting
divorced that's right
um they can stand they can handle the
truth oh you're sending
this uh he's setting something up for me
i just have a little surprise
it looks good i have a surprise for you
oh god
hold on let me can you help me go fly
while she does that
i have a question about okay no but i
have a lot of moving questions
can you hold it yes
because we don't have that much time but
we do
just want to do
a reunion oh my god
oh my god i love you i miss you
i miss you you look gorgeous so do you
where
are you can i see them i'm in kingston
[Music]
new york shooting a little indie film
it's it's actually
the um sequel to the remake of the craft
[Laughter]
yeah um they're gonna bring they're
gonna bring you into direct later we're
just like prepping
yeah no cool cool cool cool cool thank
you um
ray like why haven't you won every emmy
of course of course she doesn't hear the
compliment because she doesn't care he
doesn't have time to go to all the
stupid brunches and all the dumpsters i
know
but honestly the most brilliant the most
brilliant actor
do you remember your audition for
whitney ray
i do i do i do
why it's the car scene yes do you want
me to do it you were internet yes
uh you were in an eggplant shirt and you
cried at the end
you don't remember crying yeah you cried
in the audition
and you had like going to five auditions
a day like it was like pilot season
and this i was like you're you came in
at like six o'clock
and did it and it happened it was over
and like you just
i knew you were gonna get the job i
don't know and i knew it
but i didn't know how to say like you
got the job i had to like get like
50 men in that went to school for
marketing to say yes
like i remember crying at the test not
the original
that's what it was then you're right you
cried at the chest severe
flu and they they brought me in for a
callback and a test
and uh i think they still wanted a name
or something and you were fighting them
as well as some of the other
creatives that were on your team and um
like literally they said you have to we
right now you have to get over here and
i was like i'm
deathly ill no you had to come in and
prove yourself for a job you deserved
i don't even know that i was crying it
could have been sweat i know it was
kicking a fever it would there was
i was like no it was like you're it was
like there was
it was like it was like ancestral
pain it was like all the women before
you
and it was like all um
of the like the momentum from like the
years of being in this business and
having to
literally and figure figuratively
audition for people's approval
who had no business being the people who
give the approval out
like it was just like it felt like years
of
frustration coming out of like i'm
fucking doing this again
and i am sick and i deserve this and i'm
here
proving something i've already proven a
thousand times
i loved the role though i loved roxanne
and i'm sure zoe had the same experience
i did the first time you auditioned for
the role zoe
didn't you i had to keep doing mine over
because whitney was laughing over
oh yeah so the tape was useless
yes like i had to be the star of the
audition but you know what's funny is i
came in for roxanne
that's right and and i made you go to
the lobby i said
go to the lobby and you told me to move
over you're gonna cold read this yeah
and you said cold read for lily which i
was always
used to playing the like dry sidekick
and lily was like the sort of like
airy flaky yeah and and i had to come in
and read it cold
i was like no you look dumb actually
read this one's
insulting don't buy it
move because then zoe you brought like
all this complexity to a role that i
think other people
might have tried to play as as
single everyone came in and played it
dumb and i like to always go against and
then roxanne
was like you know the super the kim
katra the
miranda the suit they they wanted like
the super feminine
miniskirt whatever and it was like no
but they also like i remember you gave
me the note you said i just want to say
that's off the bat all the
uh we're having some trouble with the
actresses coming in or maybe they called
me and told me this is your note no you
said it to me
that um everyone was coming in and
playing her bitchy
and i remember telling you like she's
not a bitch she's helping
yeah yeah yeah helping everyone
you brought this like fragility to her
that everyone was playing her like tough
as
nails like fucking bad bitch and it was
like no she's like always about to cry
yeah and then you came in and almost
cried
every every week it was like a master
class my favorite is when
rey cause the way multi-camera works and
the way a show works when
someone's inner child is running it and
she has no idea what she's doing
the lines change a lot and when the
network's coming in saying we want
whitney to wear more purple
so then the last we need to soften her
because she has an eating disorder uh
we need i didn't know purple mask that
she looks tired
and i remember uh ray and the only other
person i've seen do this
is laurie metcalf on the set of roseanne
in her stefan wool hoodie so on a
multi-cam which a lot of people don't
take seriously they think it's like so
easy or something when in fact it's a
play
and rey is like she's she's got her cup
and her behavior and she's
got the bed she's there there's a jacket
she's putting on on the third line and
then she's
fluffing the pillow and then we'd go oh
we're cutting those two lines and you
just here go like
you just see her like
she had like she had like a pair that
she had taken
one bite of so it's like do i not take
the pair and then watching her
oh yeah like i was ready to open it
rattle stick with whatever
i just prepared and now took the shit
down
but she spent hours on this behavior and
then we go oh we're cutting that and she
and just watching the crest fallen
nature of okay so
the pair like just watching you redo the
blocking in 30 seconds
i wasn't upset i just have to think i
only recently found out i think it was
like
second season of stall and after all
these years i found out
that my thinking face looks like
that's a dumb note
by the way i i 100 know that they were
all dumb notes
but i i don't disagree with you but they
were also dumb notes
but no but if something changes so you
have to say if something changes on like
line 11
and you had planned like this ramp
together oh my god the hand
even if you're changing someone else's
line
and that was going to be one of the my
you know the mile post that's like
you're charting and then they move it
i i do this yeah yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes in my head i'm thinking like okay so
one two one okay so one did not okay so
there's not going to be a jump there and
we're not going to take a step there
that's at the time
i'll switch to here women's faces are
very
triggering if they're not smiling
women you're a bitch you're rejecting me
it's just like if a woman's not smiling
everyone can't handle it i have like
there's being palatable sure yeah i
would also say i
also think that if sometimes it's
actually a lovely thing sometimes if
someone does respect your craft and what
you're doing
they're very worried that they're going
to mess something up by like
giving you a note that's um you know
fucked up or whatever
i don't know what were you gonna say zoe
i was gonna say that i
my my approach is so like the
opposite from rey's which is why it was
so much fun to like watch her work and i
like have so much respect for how
meticulous like
i i love watching an actor who loves
business like in terms of the pillows or
like the things like
you're and when you work with like like
jimmy burroughs who's like
you know like such a um he'll be like
cross your leg
cross your leg before you say that last
word and literally you'll cross your leg
and it'll get a laugh
like what the fuck yeah i didn't
understand and i am so
like i'm like i want the props
department to stay away from me like i
just want to like
hit my mark and say the line yes yes yes
yes i don't want business
i don't want to fluff the pillow and so
it was just so it's always so easy so he
was in a pandemic before
i'm not touching anything no one comes
within six feet of me i touch nothing
she's just standing there like this for
every scene
yeah but that's like i i don't know i i
wouldn't have expected that about you
uh i would say all three of us prep
heavily heavily in our acting work and
then because then that's when you get to
be free when you get there sure because
you have thought out all those things
um sometimes yeah sometimes the props
for me are just um
they are punctuations yes for rhythm
well it's also
people aren't saying lines like people
talk it's the last thing they're doing
when they're doing something
you know we're on a podcast where it's
the first thing we're doing but normally
when people are moving around the
talking is like
we're doing business yes like i'm just i
have to have this conversation
comedy math jimmy burroughs does it but
so does um jerry zaks i
did i was an understudy that got to work
with him um
and it's the same thing he will watch an
entire scene and
uh a long long scene an act of a play
even and he'll go oh uh
marian um set your teacup down after the
line not before the line
and chris uh make sure you i want you to
cross left instead of crossing right
um and then you do the whole thing and
it and you get left yeah it's
fascinating it's such a fascinating
science
i feel like i picked pretty well you did
good
you did really good we already talked
about sort of the
the salem witch trials of me being
dragged across the media
when this came out it was the craft it
was like the precursor or the craft
i keep looking for a different word
besides proud i find
there's something oogie about telling
someone it's patronizing or something
yeah
because i knew you it's implying that i
didn't think you were going to get it i
already knew you were going to get it
it's more like relieved i'm relieved you
got the thing i knew you were going to
get
can you do a reboot instead what i
really imagine
is i feel um
i'm not surprised that's it's that's it
it's
you got what you deserved mountain you
crest what it is
i feel it's but it's also
the process by which the grace by which
you
get there zoey i was
i was having all sorts of personal
emotional problems during whitney and my
work was my solace
as always very lovely about like a
like a social neediness i had that was
from other shit
and and i didn't notice because i was
starving
incredible amount of talent
you also were taking like you were
wearing like five yeah
yeah i don't know i was wearing five
leather jackets but um
i was wearing a gun now clothes you were
but you you had this incredible amount
of talent
and you do two things with it that are
very inspiring to me and i remind myself
of it um a lot when i need
to and that that you try you get out of
your own way
a lot you're like you have these dreams
of
of of how talented you are and what
you're capable of that i think
most artists this far along in the
business have but then we
crush ourselves a couple hours later we
go no no you can't do that or you're not
going away and then the second thing you
do is you have this humility
and this um insatiable curiosity
to actually learn from other people and
get better along the way so that once
that opportunity happens and i'm looking
at a trailer for the craft
i'm like that's blowing me away and not
too getting out of your own way but also
getting better with every single job so
it's
applying the lessons you learned a lot
of us need to learn them over and over
again and something i'll say this is
making me think of something zoe did
which was very triggering to me at the
time because i didn't understand what it
was
which is zoe
does not allow you to
uh create a space that makes it so she
can't do her best work you hired me to
do my best work so i'm gonna need to set
some boundaries and ask for some things
i need so that i can deliver for you
like there were times where zoe would
say like whether i need another take or
i don't get this line i'd be like oh
well like
at the time because i was in so much
fear and
emotional perfectionism it was like i
didn't understand that
that's her doing her job her it is
also our job to claim space and make
sure
that we are able to do our best work and
sometimes
at the time i when people set boundaries
or took care of themselves that was
threatening to me
because i didn't i didn't understand
that that's what they were doing it was
like a rejection or a judgment it felt
like a judgment to me
you're telling me i'm failing in some
way because my ego is
running the show and my fear so it's
like zoey even on her first job
where you think you're like walking on
eggshells and i'll do anything you say
it was like she was like no it's
part of my job is to make sure i can do
my job
and sometimes that means setting
boundaries and saying no
and disagreeing with you and i didn't
know that's what she was doing at the
time
but that's such a i think important
thing for women and anyone in a position
of not power to go
harder for women you hired me to stand
up to you
so that i can deliver
thank you so much you guys okay bye i
can't believe
it's like the this like it's very it's
very emotional
it's very intense and you're both saying
the most
beautiful things and i am so um
i'm really like so so grateful it's
intense
for both of you and it's like it's very
emotional because it's like
we really all have you're like in
fucking should be bitch i'm saying
really nice things
um it is it's intense we all
met each other at a real um turning
point
and i think all of us were at a point
that was like
uh very um yeah like like even just
hearing the story of you crying in that
test
you know it can be so debilitating and
destabilizing as an artist
to be told no so many times and that we
were able to sort of
so many times yeah and that like
by the time someone says yes
you're almost too broken and worn down
to like i mean it's like what we say i
would say like the only thing worse than
actors not working is like actors
getting a job no actors are miserable
until we get
the job right you know what i mean
because then you have the job and now
you're dealing with all these
complicated personalities and you have
to believe in yourself
and be a star when everyone told you you
weren't a star for so long so then
there's like the imposter syndrome too
of like i'm here and now i don't know
what the fuck to do when i'm here
and i don't know how to claim my own
space and do my best work and we were
all in the in a
in a space of fear together you know i
mean we all had
our different feelings not just because
crystalline that were
co-mingling you know and like um
and and i think like it is you know what
you guys are saying to
to me is is so meaningful and i cannot
thank you enough for all of your like
bolstering words but like it is so
incredible to watch
both of your paths like you know like
just that we were there together and
then
like ray just to see the unbelievable
work you've continued to do
that has taken the world by storm and
whitney to see
not only your like growth as a fucking
empire
but like where you've taken on you've
taken on the business
where you've given yourself such an
incredible amount of agency that is so
inspiring and powerful and such a
incredible example for so many women
and all people because i i i mean you
guys were there
when it was all we want to do is put on
plays
for people and make them laugh and feel
and move and heal ourselves and them and
heal
we want to be healers right but the
number of people we had to ask for
permission the number of gatekeepers
that we had to
tap dance for shape-shift for walk on
eggshells around
um uh compliment
make think they could fuck us at some
point
i mean that's very real i mean there's i
got a lot of opportunities because
i flirted and made someone believe
they could date me but i couldn't give
too much because then they needed to i
mean that was a very
real form of power that we had until
very recently
i just taught by an uh a working actress
in in acting school she came and told us
what to do to get a job she's an
audition as a first date
yeah and i was like yes okay no i know
actresses that didn't wear underwear to
the auditions
and you know what i mean crosstalk i
mean it's like a that was
never i was never flirty and i i'm
and ray's like and i've made i've made a
program with integrity so you guys need
to shut the fuck up like i don't know
i did it with talent yeah she's like
what is this
i overcame
the need to do that i was just too
talented
that's true i was heavier set when i
started and so no one would let me
anywhere near onge new roles at all i
played all these character roles and it
was the best
training and experience ever and then by
the time i
just got healthy for myself i started
auditioning for on-camera stuff and i
was a blonde
a white blonde blue-eyed woman that
immediately was going to be asked to
come in for dumb girlfriend parts and
like i didn't
i didn't know what i just thought like
well clearly we have to make them
interesting like she
oh she's just she just lets this guy
shit on her she must be like
broken and damaged or on drugs and like
that's how it would approach the
audition
yeah yeah yeah oh because no woman would
oh my god but the feedback would be
um you put subtext where there was no
subtext well they would say
she just needs to be a lot more feminine
that's what's in her way
that's the feedback i got all the time
through my agent um
i was like what does that even mean
well in one case they actually pressed i
said i need you to get more feedback to
my agent because
i said it's not even like when i first
started auditioning on camera i need to
be
dumber and weaker yes basically
and simpler i need to be simpler ask her
questions she just always has an answer
be dumber simpler less dimensional
you're just two-dimensional
um but i also had to work a little bit
on uh
fighting a fight that wasn't there and
uh insisting on
wearing giant sweatpants to auditions
that is for
like um a hot agent yeah yeah
i was really going like yeah not this
woman i'm gonna
yeah i'm gonna prove a point yeah
and not get a job um and i was whitney
you said something to me that i have not
i've forgotten and i have to touch upon
time and time again and that was i
understand what chargement imposter
syndrome which i'm fascinated with and
have but it was more like
um i have imposter syndrome i think i'm
as talented as you
which is what's got me so far
you are um but i didn't and this was
going on during
it was a turning point for me of like i
have lost
my sense of self value when i am not
working
i understood that although i had doubts
i understood like i know how to do my
job and if i work hard i put my head
down
and really fucking figure those props
out like
i can be value added to a story but um
the second i left i did not understand
my value in the world and when you said
something it might have
been in your book or something you said
to me i can't remember about um
starting the day thinking you're zero
until you produce something
and then like you get like a point for
everything you made today or
accomplished is somehow your self-worth
but then you're starting at zero
is is this a test yeah and that is where
i was yeah it's um i outsource my
self-esteem
and you know look productivity and
cooperation makes dopamine that's
there's a biological basis for that but
yeah
it was like my self-worth i had a linear
relationship uh between my
uh self-worth and what i had made or
produced you know so it was
um which is a goose chase because i
didn't think i was enough
you know like you really find out what
you think of yourself when you do
nothing all day
are you a piece of shit are you nothing
because i had a chronic i'm falling
behind thing as well
my and i think that as you know we were
just talking about as women in our
age group if another woman got something
i lost a point and i'm our i'm falling
behind
and the in the root of i'm falling
is there's an expiration date
coming so you're only falling behind
if you're going to run out of time at
some point so there was a clock on women
and i
mine was always like 45 like i had like
you have till 45.
like i had a thing we have it with you
have to get married by you have to get
have a baby bye you have to be
get famous bye because then i expire
i i had this not self-imposed yes
internalized socially constructed who
cares where it came from of
you only have a certain amount of time
high def television is real
it's a magnifying glass and i remember
do you remember
the first uh uh when you
were on high def and you uh it showed
freckles and we had to take him out and
pose so did i ever tell you that
no oh we used to take your freckles out
and pose
why because
well did you know that on whitney i was
animated did you know that in post they
would
um this is why everything everyone
thinks i'm such a bad actress because
all any nuanced stuff that i was doing
in my face they took out and post
oh yeah you don't remember i remember
that okay so i were you coming into the
makeup room and being like
your lipstick is too loud on high death
i remember and then michael patrick king
later called it dimensional
so someone more talented agreed with me
yeah because that was really
you were wearing a neon poppy yeah you
were hiding
your talent behind that neon poppy or i
was amplifying yeah that's
you're being too loud yeah you had lines
even when you weren't talking and i
you were in an ensemble sometimes you
need to shine
you have to do what you gotta do to
steal focus
zoe's stealing focus
but i tell you a fucked up story is that
i studied at the atlantic uh theater
company acting school
and um and yeah i'm going to say it on
this podcast david mamet came and gave
us a uh
um guest class and said to me
um he he complimented me he was sort of
like
famously gruff and so everyone gets
super scared
when when you'd like because he would
show up out of nowhere and you have to
like
um dad yeah you have to like put
something up for him that he
might not be prepared to like a scene
that you've been working on whatever
and he was really such a god at that
school and you know in in the theater
community at large
and um and i put up a scene that i had
written
and it was really scary but i was like
fuck it you know
i'm gonna see what happens yeah and he
he usually would cut people off halfway
through
which was so brutal and he let me get
through it and then he said who wrote
that and i said i did
he said you should you should keep
writing and it was so beautiful
but then afterwards he came up to me and
he said why are you here
and i said like i was i was like what do
you mean like this is your acting school
like i'm here to learn a craft
yeah and he was like well your shelf
life is short
what as in why are you you should be a
writer not an actress
no i think acting wise he was like you
should just be
go out there no go out there and start
working oh yeah yeah
shelf life as a as an on-camera presence
because
your looks are all that matters so don't
worry about the craft because and at the
time he might have been right
he might have not known the shift that
was coming
you know what i mean he's never i mean
he was right in that i mean there is
that thing
that i'm on his side amazing honestly
but it was
so discouraging like as a young woman
who has who was so excited to be so if
your career now if this is you
discouraged imagine like david mamet
held you back
this is you disco this is you at your
like lowest
uh success yeah because he thwarted you
well wow i remember we were at the you
did practical
i didn't i don't think i knew that so
it's practical handbook right yeah
aesthetics whatever
yeah that's my that's my basis for
training but don't tell me you don't do
that
shitty that insane prep i don't do that
prep ray
i do not i i hate that prep
no zoey picked on nars lipstick i didn't
train there that's just the book they
taught where i was
i remember we were at a wrap party for
whitney
uh a wrap party and i always thought
the key because i was like reading books
on how to be a boss like i was just like
i was like i'm a boss now i have to
figure it out so i would like to read
these books at like two in the morning
and uh like how to win friends and
influence like how to you know
and one of them is like know everybody's
name all the time so i was like i'm
gonna know everyone's name because it
was like i'm a woman i'm in charge
people already hate me
i'm already the actress so the writers
in the room hate me because i'm the
actress and the actors hate me because
i'm also the writer you know it's like
i'm
i ever i'm triggering everyone and i'm
uh
uh you know also have no idea what i'm
doing right
and then uh so i learned like know
everybody's names and that was my whole
thing so i'd stay up at night i would
memorize the whole
cast cast i had to learn your names
finally
um i would memorize the whole crew list
right because i was like oh they're
gonna think i'm
equal to them and like hey john look him
in the eye like no one's gonna feel
abandoned and rejected by me and they're
gonna do their best work and this is all
gonna go
get fixed and the ad campaigns are gonna
come down or whatever i was hoping you
know i'm gonna stop being like
you know humiliated in the press and uh
and so i was at the wrap party and there
was someone whose name i didn't know and
i was like oh no
you know i have to go introduce myself
to this person i was like hi i don't
know you what's your name and he was
like oh i'm john i was like oh what do
you do on the show like i'm a good boss
and he was like oh i fix your face in
post i was like what
i was like what do you mean he's like oh
yeah i take out your under eye circles
in post and i was like
oh wow to be fair he didn't need to be
that specific
no oh to be fair he has asperger's yeah
that he panicked and then you could have
said i mean i'm in post
i'm in post he said i'm the one that
takes out well he was proud of his work
i mean that's the other thing he's like
i'm the one that
helped he and he thought he was yeah you
know
he's saying something good he was
helping he was you know he didn't know
that i didn't know
so i only was told you have to turn in
cuts five days sooner i didn't know
i would they lied to me about or they
didn't tell me um which is probably
the right that was probably the right
thing to do um in retrospect but yeah so
i look like um marzipan in the show it's
just i look like a piece of cake
i look like a pound cake it comes up a
lot for which yeah is that is it a
favorite food she has like five or six
words she likes to rotate through
she called the craft legacy um visual
mars visual marzipan
it's so creamy it looks it's like
it's like oh god well i was on bad wi-fi
i was in the air it was jetblue wi-fi
yeah it was it's animated right
it's a cartoon right it's you shot the
whole thing out of focus right
on purpose she hasn't even seen it yet
she's just to make it a dreamlike state
yeah it just took her two hours to watch
the trailer yeah
it was so bad look at your wedding
finger oh my god yeah
still not married still engaged take
your time
the best ever so hot
so hot it's really hot so hot we waited
nine years to get married yeah
that's right that's right
yeah well how long what how long till
the craft comes till this podcast is
over
we've got three or four more hours um on
this one i
uh the craft comes out on october 28th
today oh
today oh my god we love you thank you
for
um doing this this is our reunion this
is our whitney reunion
well we'll do a real one when i get back
yes for sure um
congrats to both of you i love you
inspiring congrats everybody i mean
you're
better call saul unbelievable come on
unbelievable work
thank you give her all the awards all
the awards
let's give me all the awards yeah you
don't have time to do all the bullshit
brunches and shit that are actually what
get
people the awards because they buy
awards because you're working oh i
should get more money then i didn't no
you have to like
people don't know they're like the
bullshit of awards it's all like
who's willing to go to the most
breakfasts
um i love breakfast yeah and then the
studio has to pay yeah like all the
awards are bought yeah
you're missing i feel like you're not
the takeaway
which is was the line that roxanne said
in her audition scene not the takeaway
not the takeaway not the takeaway um all
right
i'm going to set we're doing an
all-night shoot oh my god i love you
i'm so happy to be working love you
bye bye bye guys
come on what a surprise am i taking
these off yes these now come off and
benton what was your question about
we'll write back in it okay because i'm
gonna pee
i have a lot okay i know it's your turn
so
first of all i just wanna know or say
for everyone that's going to watch this
that maybe had my expectations that the
way that you go about introducing us
into these moments from the original
craft
is so new and respectful like the way
that you threw in light as a feather
stiff as a board where it was like a
moment and not like this
thing remember this thing guys everybody
remember this like yes we remember
and you gave us so many new moments to
attach to
was golden thank you but there's one i
don't want to give too much of the movie
away there's one scene specifically in
this movie that really stuck out to me
where they are
talking with um this male character who
has had this like
rebirth into this like new identity and
we'll see how he gets there anything
but where they hang out with him and
kind of invite him into this room to sit
in this circle together
that for me i was like i don't know it
was like it was really kind of powerful
for me
because i was like as someone who has
watched this movie and kind of gone
through life
whereas like for me like well i identify
as a man obviously i'm very happy being
a man
i'm having a good time doing it like
it's fine but i
feel very much attached to like female
energy and women
in that space and specifically like with
this movie
that seeing this scene where they're
like inviting him to be part of this
circle
i was like oh that's me like i kind of
felt seen i was like that's
for me yeah i mean i won't get the rest
of the movie obviously what happens but
i was like
that's like really important i think for
a lot of people because in the first
in the original you had to like i said
you had to look for yourself and in this
one i was like i didn't have to at all
i don't know i feel like i was a part of
it and if i'm not a part of the next one
i'll be very excited
were there any major challenges or
disasters on the shoot
um like you know i think sometimes i see
you coming right into my emotional store
and you're like anyways
are there any challenges
no i'm not those drinks please i'm sorry
but i need one of your old drinks
hopefully one day what is it benton
posted the other day someone oh
how nicole richie used to work for clint
kim or chloe carter
he posted like one day but also kim was
paris's assistant wasn't she
i think that's a very inspiring story
for us is it
well they don't work for them now but
isn't that nice yeah benton
uh showed up one day and he was like uh
he was like i heard lady gaga's former
assistant just made
uh four hundred thousand dollars on a
book deal i'm like million dollars four
million dollars in a booktube i'm like
easy like why tell me what you're gonna
do look i'm shaking telling you that no
studying for me
me how exciting for me having my own
moment in the corner guys guess what i
said
but we're manifesting i mean that's what
benton does right he manifests
so he's coming in to say i'm about to
make 400 or 4 million dollars
benton look there benton can achieve
whatever he want i was on benton's
vision board
okay how many times was i on your vision
board four
i was how when did you make the vision
board i made that vision board in
2009 i believe when i was a freshman in
college and lisa kudrow from the
comeback was also on it who you worked
with on the pilot with amazon
she was on it uh what on your vision
board has not come true i don't have a
blue check mark
you don't have a video working on it
that wasn't on your passion
yes it is that's on my vision board a
big giant blue check mark right on there
because uh it's very specific about it
okay so we're working on it
a range rover yeah there's a lot of cars
on there a lot of awards being on a book
list but i'll be very honest i
have a very positive attitude about my
vision board i was just something i put
up
and i just looked at it it was almost i
look at vision boards like little
prayers kind of like
this is what it is and that's what i
kind of look at but so you got
me i mean it sort of backfired no i got
you in a really cool way i think yeah
way better than i could have
because the vision board was just like
those are careers that i might made my
vision board these are
careers or people that i would like to
mimic their their careers mm-hmm
and i kind of got you in a totally
different way than that it was like i
got the real you
live in my house yeah i wasn't even
mimicking i got the actual you
and then um so i mean
that's wild is it because you're it's
it's wild to think about and then you
just walked up to me at a show
and i was like come live with me yeah i
mean it's
really strange that vision board and so
you now
like i think the crap we all are witches
that's what you're saying yeah olivia
mama's on my vision board
and she's not my friend
but that is the thing is like we all
like it is a matter of
we're manifesting energy i think that's
crazy yeah and i think that what the the
craft does
i think what this movie does is like all
the things that people told you was
crazy
hippy dippy silly psychic
bullshit metaphysical we malign that
that's there's
there's a very long tradition in our
species
of rolling our eyes at ambition
especially women having ambition or
someone others not
having ambition having big dreams is
like
it's embarrassing i was
i'm still to this day i get like when
someone says what do you want to do i'm
like i don't know whatever this is fine
yeah
we want but and i think there's a
biological basis for making ourselves
small and not
uh wanting too much or stealing light
you know well then you can't fail if i
never tell you that's right
yes i can't and if you don't celebrate
your successes then you can't be
disappointed on the other end yeah
but also it's like you're asking for too
much who do you think you are syndrome
uh we're made to feel and i think this
is kind of changing with the next
generation i think that
what we view as like arrogant and like
this next
generation that's like me me me me we're
just kind of like we think that's gross
because we were conditioned to
be smarter where's the next generation's
like no this is how we make money
yeah like which one is business being
confident and ambitious is
lucrative in the legacy there's so many
of these little and again this could be
me projecting there's so many little
layers of like
it doesn't even have to be like magic
per se it's just like you can do this
thing if you have a group of people that
believe in you yes and it's just like
yeah that's your crew
you don't have to take power from people
you can get your own power
you don't have to take it there's all
these like layers it's like all the
ships rise with you
yes and that is it's such a paradigm
shift when you go there yeah
because it is me or you yeah and then
it's like oh no both of us together
yeah it's like joe rogan is really who
showed that in the podcast space i mean
as someone that like
kind of single-handedly is like
dismantling this other byzantine
uh uh smoke and mirrors of we all have
to ask permission of these people with
these kind of fake jobs that they don't
deserve
but were uh complicit in the gaslighting
because
we're agreeing to them and we're giving
them the power that we have
we're giving them our we're giving them
the ability to give us permission for a
thing we already
can do we just didn't have the cameras
we didn't have the distribution arm they
had all the distribution they had the
um you know the tvs and the bandwidth
and the fucking wires or however shit
shows up
and now it's like the power has been
restored it's like you know i got really
emotional on the plane when it was like
we've been unbound
it's like that really is like what i
feel like has like happened
to me in the last like couple months of
like and i'm sorry that a pandemic is
is why it happened but i think you know
the internet really
is like has made the people that never
got to have voices be unbound
yes because there's no gatekeepers mine
would have been better
can we do mine again yeah let's take it
back um
um i agree and i think like part of what
unbound and can we just say what i'm
bound means
because i also like important i want
people to leave this
podcast saying unbound
because you might be bound right now and
your now
goal after this podcast has become
unbound after you watch the movie
now available well binding is a practice
in witchcraft which you could probably
speak to too
but it's if someone um you know is a
danger to themselves or others
through a ritual you can bind them um
and in the film what i wanted to look at
also was the ways in which those who are
in which in which those who are like
marginalized
often bind themselves
because they're being told that they
should
want less or they don't deserve more or
they should make themselves small
because they don't fit into
what we've done yeah or you have a
show yeah but it really just means
you're a threat yeah but it means you're
a threat and so like
in in in the film the girls actually end
up
deciding to bind their own powers and
that is
i think especially when those you know
those of us
who have it's it's that it's that
self-doubt
that so many of us struggle with to say
you know what i'm actually going to step
back from this
i'm going to step back from this power
because of what we've been taught is
it's going to overwhelm me and
it's going to be out of my control and
instead i think and other people
if i'm big other people will feel small
and i need to make other people feel
big yeah it makes me safer i mean
there's a biological basis for it but
it's like
obsolete now yeah now is the i need to
not take up too much space not be too
loud
you know i think that for the longest
time you know
those without power they stayed safe by
us washing the person with power and
being
you know what i'm saying staying small
so they didn't feel like we were because
so they didn't feel threatened and they
felt threatened they'd kill us there's
that great quality you know if you don't
if
you don't work on building your own
dream you spend your whole life helping
someone build their
mm-hmm and that's very much i think what
we're kind of taught to do by being a
shame thank you for doing that by the
way yeah and he's about done with
building your dream
and being like little whatever face
sarah my gender
and being like the last stop on this
train
[Laughter]
like a prize yeah yeah i just he goes
poof he just wishes i
just disappeared but there is but it is
like one of those i mean in college i
had a
i had my teacher told me i went for
marketing emergency for design
and i was like i would like to work at
vogue and she literally said to me she's
like you'll never get to go to vogue i
went to vogue the first week i was
went through the first week remember in
new york that's amazing
and i mean i mean it wasn't for me but i
still went in i got into the building
yeah and i think like those are i just
think people do that a lot
people put their limitations on
themselves for themselves on you
yeah their own fears no you couldn't do
it ma'am that doesn't do no you couldn't
do it
yeah that doesn't mean i can't do it i
had a a teacher
in uh acting school who
like he was sensing that like i started
directing
it was a sketch comedy class i started
people started asking me to direct their
sketch comedy things i i was the
director
of the artistic director of like our
little sketch comedy group and um
and then mammoth came and gave gave me
that compliment publicly and so there
are all these things and he
i found out later he was known to do
this but um every year he would choose a
different woman to do this too
um and he was not not never fired for
doing so
but basically you're getting her child
tonight um my inner child was like i'm
here for this story actually this was
very upsetting to me
about this man
the trauma is very much living
um he and he basically like at
completely out of nowhere and i was on
an academic scholarship
he gave me a uh a failing grade at a
where i had i was like really i did put
my best work in that class i had perfect
attendance i was the artistic director
and then he wrote like a two-page um
single-spaced evaluation that went to
the entire school
that said that he would make sure that i
never worked again
in this industry and um it was like
just such an abusive evaluation in
addition to like me being like well this
is also impacting my academic
scholarship and it's
so clear and i ended up being the first
um i think
student at that school to take him on
because
these incidences had been brushed under
the rug for years before
where he would because he was really
like he i remember there was like one
there's a real tangent but i just you
know the inner child needs to talk uh
there was one
one like um there was a mormon
student a woman who um she asked what a
wet willy was
in class and he licked his finger and
stuck it in her ear
he called all of us babe and honey and
sweetie and then
um at this one point he when i was
directing these young women you are kind
of a babe
he he told these um
these young women were like trying to do
like a handshake like a funny handshake
for their sketch
and he was like twister titty twister
titty for the handshake so just like
these moments
where we were all just a little bit like
this feels really uncomfortable for us
as young women and uh you're our
professor and
you know we're 19 years old and and the
fact that he did it meant
so many people went along with it for so
long so long and then he would take
and i think any woman who in his
situation he would in his classroom he
would see
which woman would sort of stand up which
is sort of what you were talking about
it was like
if like i i was the one to say like
you're the problem i'm not okay i'm not
okay with this
um which i never even went up to it is
such a
it is this industry industry specific
awareness predator and prey yeah
yeah just and predators are wild huh
acting teachers are wild they
never say anything helpful well they
they have like one favorite student
it's their job i remember the first um
place that i went and the scientologists
are gonna come for me but um
the first place i went in la whoa
i just got scared for the first time and
not much scares me but
except scientologists yeah um uh
we'll decide if we cut it out um there's
an acting school in l.a
and oh yes yes and i went to this in the
beginning and it's like not
i don't like acting i i still don't i'm
not totally sure what it is
you know what i mean i'm acting right
now we're always acting but you know
what i mean when are we acting
whatever it's just cameras are here so
it's acting i guess yeah um
uh and they would basically just try to
break you down psychologically
and have you trauma bond with them and
try to make it's a cult i mean it's to
make you their master it's like it's
nexium 101. you know
teacher was so mean my acting tutor
tried to convince me
like that i was molested like in front
of the whole class
yeah i'm always in front of the whole
class you know which i'm sure i was
but it was like but and then they kind
of gaslight you into believing that
you're gonna solve uh they're gonna
solve the problem that they created
right which is why so many actors then
entered into nexium
like yeah like like legit but truly
legit they would they would when they
said that the places they would recruit
were acting schools and yoga
studios it all made sense
i was like okay i mean scientology goes
to a meetings and acting studios
someone needs to stop acting teacher you
just need to cancel
this woman i'm coming after the ballet
in my next special
and we also should come after acting
teacher i mean my teacher would have me
stand in front of all
our group and she would just be like say
that but don't be funny now say it again
now say it again and they should be like
change your voice
change do a different voice that's a
sadistic person yeah who's crazy
that's a power trip and then she would
say bye to everybody but me at the end
of the day
i remember yeah well but she was
threatened by your power
and your talent that's what i think i
think it's important to talk about
jealousy and being threatened by
people's power
yes and what that does and that's what
actually did that stand up if someone
doesn't like you
what does that mean that means they're
jealous of you and threatened by your
power
or you're a meanie yeah i mean
yeah i will say this about manifesting
things which is um
uh when i bought my first house which i
couldn't afford
you told me bet on yourself
which is also why it's the house that
whitney built because i wasn't
i've always and continued to operate
from a place of scarcity
and you were like you will afford that
house you can't afford it now but you
will
why ain't that the pot calling the
cattle blood
that's so interesting you have all these
words of wisdom for everyone the very
first show i ever did with whitney where
she invited me to that guest spot when i
got off stage
i opened the green room door and it's a
really small green room
i opened the green room door and she's
standing in the doorway like this and
she was looking at me and i was like
already nervous this could be you know
and she was like do you do this a lot
and i was like oh my god did i do a bad
job and i was like oh i mean sometimes
if i get to open for someone there's
like a we get like a group like this and
she went
well you should do it all the time and
then just sat down and i was like okay
yeah well that is similar to when we
first met and she said like
why aren't you famous like it wasn't
like it came from almost a place of
anger yeah
it was like it was like it was a hassle
like it was an option
well no it's just like no one's handled
this yet it was just like it's it's to
me
like most of the things that i do that
come on uh that are like whatever kris
jenner or the kris jenner and me
is like no one's gonna make i so i'm the
one that has to make this person famous
it's like that it's like shooting
stand-up specials and stuff in my
backyard i'm like i just kept waiting
for someone else to do it no one would
so i just like end up doing it yeah
because no one else
you know is a virgo um people are very
girls
yeah i i i'm also we just wanna let
everyone know we do know that more of
you exist
i know whitney thinks that she owns it
every virgo thinks they're the only
version she learned about zodiac signs
this year
all of a sudden she's like um i invented
them isn't that weird
no they're mine um no but i
i love that uh uh when i
home is the most important thing so my
thing is
well if you don't buy the house you're
not gonna make the money to afford the
house because your home is where you're
gonna
thrive and know that's your you know
yeah that's your creative space so it's
like
um how are you ever gonna afford a house
if you don't buy this house
it's just like to me that just like it's
i grew up in an alcoholic home
i knew home was the only thing that
mattered your space and like
you know i think that what's important
for people that are listening is like
instagram there's birken bags and
there's shoes and there's gucci purses
and there's crystal water bottles and
there's the bullshit and there's all the
snake oil the snake well the snake oil
all the snake oil vented yeah that's a
secret okay shut up
all the snake oil and you know
we don't talk about financial
gaslighting and we don't you know in
this business in every business we talk
about sexual abuse
we're not talking about financial abuse
and the way that because i believe money
is
is your your ability to be solvent
that's your ability to get out of a bad
situation you know for women making
money it's like women want money
it's not to buy purses women want to
make as much money as men because so
they can buy more tampons like that's
not what we're doing it's like the
tampons are expensive they are pink
hashtag
um that's a whole other conversation but
um yeah i know tampons are like
13. it's cot and then cotton balls right
next to the tampons
are 50 cents that's right it's the same
product that's right and they put some
perfume in it because our pussies need
to smell
like anything but appearing like a
period's happening
yeah um tampons in my car rear view
mirror as an air freshener for the car
i actually think this is part of the
reason we bonded so hard so fast when i
got into benton's car when we were in
kentucky
yeah immediately started going through
everything just always always
always zoe what happens when i walked
the first time i walked into your house
opened every cabinet
it was really intense and continues too
yeah
yeah when i whenever i walk into someone
else's space or a home i have to just
open all the cabinets immediately
what are you looking for what's there
skeletons i'm looking for whatever's
there i don't know what's behind all the
walls the doors
right right so as soon as i walk into a
home i instantly just open all the
cabinets
don't invite her to your house don't
ever invite her to your home
[Laughter]
or clean out the cabinets we um i don't
care what's in there i just need to know
what it is yeah there's no judgment
yeah um yours is it's like all like it's
all vitamins
powders zoe is my favorite person to
like go to lunch or dinner with because
you like
order and then she'll be like i'll have
a water and two lemons i mean she'll be
ordering a spell
um she's like i'll have two lemons and
one mouse tail uh
and three egg shells and then your food
will come and then as soon as the waiter
comes over with her like
half a lemon two orange rinds and
whatever it's six grains of salt
whatever she's ordered
um then she'll just reach into her purse
so you'll literally be
be sitting there literally be sitting
eating like you'll get your salad so we
somehow just reach in her person just by
being like
she's brought her food you brought your
food today
oh no no no i need to correct this i do
not bring food to a restaurant
i bring supplements i bring supplements
i bring herbs herbs and
vitamins she just pulls like an actual
cactus i mean she's mary poppins like
the things that start coming out of her
purse
she's like i mean there's always like at
least
like what i do take
too many supplements i am a true
nightmare to eat out with
and i always try to preface that because
i feel really bad for the weight staff
mm-hmm
yeah as soon as somebody starts like
because i also sense everyone else's
embarrassment and humiliation
because you're empathic so what happens
and what is it we're at a restaurant
let's just do what we're we're at a
restaurant
may i take your order yeah
well first of all i go yes um
can i ask you can i answer a few
questions
what's your birthday i say can i ask you
a few questions
and then i'm like we're fully involved
with acting
and you can be the mean acting teacher
okay okay yeah
okay hold on um um uh hello ma'am hey
guys what's up
hey how's it going hi hi hi hi
um can i ask you a few questions sure so
i don't eat gluten dairy
soy or nightshades also corn
um emma can you tell me what's safe on
this menu
and then they okay go ahead i was gonna
act for you and that's my nightmare also
so can you tell me like is the okay is
the chicken
is the chicken free of those things what
was the chicken's name
is it chicken free of those things and
it is the chicken organic
mm-hmm
and then hold on wait where's my purse
i'll
show you because i actually have my
pills and then the and then we get zoe's
first wait it's right there
because i would like to go through zoe's
no no oh we can yes we can
so okay uh the chicken's name was hank
is that enough information for you did
the chicken have depression
well i do believe that you ingest an
animal's energy
yeah that's you do i only eat depressed
animals yeah you do consume that's why
i'm so depressed yeah
yeah you do consume fear yeah so and
because all animals when they're getting
killed they feel fear
exactly into their muscles yeah yeah
that's right different podcasts so can
you
but you haven't answered my question man
yes sir sorry back it but um yeah is it
gluten dairy
and a lot of the times that well they'll
be like let me run back to the kitchen
and ask
let me go quit real quick who's the
waiter in this scenario
me right you're just asking questions
back oh no sorry i know because i got
out of character
yeah um crazy horn um okay so
uh what come again you need me to list
it again uh
no but i was just asking about the
chicken does the chicken have
is it gluten and dairy free those are
really the biggest ones does chicken
never have gluten like did you mean did
the
was the chicken free diet the chicken i
don't appreciate when it was alive
but um but the chicken might be breaded
no not breaded or the sauce might have
flour in it the chicken is just straight
up chicken
straight up chicken no butter is there
butter
it's ghee okay well i don't do ghee okay
i also don't do coconut okay am i losing
fans on this podcast
not really no um yeah no cause it was it
was
and now you see why on set triggered
so um uh no to all great okay i'll have
the chicken thank you so much
and then it's fine i'm dead or alive oh
i'd like to slaughter it myself
okay so please oh please so then this is
going to be now we're
roll reversing i'm playing zoey
in irl yep uh you are
directing okay i love this one you're
directing
me as you as me yes
okay great wait what am i gonna do i
wanna be somebody
um
[Applause]
are we in this scenario because you know
i think i'm getting dragged a lot but
like
i feel like this is how people feel at
burning man when the man burns
whatever just happened and then zoey's
head's not cut off right no can you stop
thank you
can you stop so much like um katy perry
in the morning oh
thank you she like came from old money
she's victorian katy perry don't you
think so look especially when you were
crying earlier i was like whoa
oh but she's also like brunette kate
blanchett
oh and oh my god that's a nice thing
also um
mary pickford mary pickford and
what who i don't think she's made out of
butter and i don't eat butter and she
doesn't even i don't even eat it i don't
go near it she would never eat herself
okay let's turn the monitor off
um okay um okay so here's my chicken
okay here's hmm sure yes thank you
because benton won't stop um
me i wasn't even talking about me so
nice about me okay so
so here's my 90s backpack yeah okay
because i'm just a 90s bitch
and i remade the craft okay so first i'm
gonna put my
boron i'm sorry i uh
uh no i'm sorry shit i'm not yeah i'm
gonna put my if i'm you then i would be
like
oh my god i have listen i have such a
good boron recipe myself listen listen i
know someone who knows someone
who can get you boring i'll mail it
right to your house do you have an
address where do you live where do you
come right on their address someone get
their address anyone that's your camera
i know you're looking at this one i'm
you i'll tell me where
and i want to look right there how come
the camera's not facing me already
shouldn't all three cameras catch me who
put the cameras up
oh oh yeah because yeah um now i'm gonna
eat my uh
candies uh i mean i definitely don't
narrate while i do it i do like
so whitney when you're when you're doing
this and and i love what you've done so
far thank you
um but i think that when you pull it out
maybe just um it's more like that you're
a little embarrassed and so you're gonna
like right i've shaved
it and then someone's going to say what
is that and you're like oh
it's a it's a mineral yeah yeah you're
giving me a like i wrote a book about
shane
i don't know if you guys knew um it's
fine i'll sit back here though i'll just
sit back here if you guys want to talk
about shame like
i probably don't know anything about it
anyways probably
this is my favorite acting exercise oh
that's my weave okay yep
um this is my weave sorry guys i'm sorry
yeah i would never take that on my back
that's uh um you just travel with
someone else's hair
okay sorry that's for spells magnolia
does anyone have any um
organic scissors so that i can open this
i'll just use my teeth it's fine
there's a lot of diamond in my tooth as
long
um this is my magnolia clear sinus
yeah gotta keep it tighter what the fuck
is this
why are you opening it it's clearly
closed first but i mean
the only thing crazier than having an
open bottle of magnolia clear sinus in
your purse is having one that's not you
i'm surprised it's not open
it's just a gnc at this point it's well
there's even more in there no i'm
i'm oh that's that's gi
i care yeah well because she's got a
jewish stomach for sure
things don't go down these all go before
you eat all the bottles at one time well
so this is a good question
like a little pill case that's right
yeah well but the thing is so that's a
that's a digestive enzyme and then you
eat this before you
these so the herbs if you're listening
to this and not watching it bless your
heart i love you you're
this is just asmr at this point this is
an asmr so
um this is magnolia clear sinus and it
helps me
um it never helps you haven't opened it
no i haven't opened that oh that's on
super groups
that's a great sense for you yes but you
really have to dig through that shit
um but you wear hats you dress like a
beekeeper when you
i do i wear a visor or a hat right and
this is a sample of biology
i got a lot of samples so ila powder
for her perfect sunscreen skin just
loosely in the bag
this is a thing and by the way as a
virgo and i always forget what like my
rising sign is or whatever
this bag looks like my
hippocampus like i'm looking at this bag
and i just
it's i'm like looking in a mirror really
yeah because that's surprising to me and
maybe you could speak to this
as an astrologer which you are now
you are just giving me jobs new jobs
yeah like
why this is so whitney cummings this is
saho
whitney cummings two open bottles of the
same
activation and one to half so i know i
can enjoy the one i'm using
because i'm always afraid that i'm gonna
be like and then one
two of two open at the same
fullness how can i use the one i bought
if i have another one that's open
right scarcity complex yeah but this is
my question is like why as a virgo
because i am organized in so many other
like areas of my life why it does why is
this what my bag looks like
because whitney's car
something exploded in there yeah but why
are we like this when we're so organized
in other words
but it's but this is organization this
is prepared we're also prep
but this is what it is it's at every
point something could go wrong yeah
i'm prepared for anything to happen
because you couldn't find anything to
have
it's not you're we're humans as we
talked about our uh
uh robert green said like we're
irrational creatures you're acting as if
we're rational
yeah you know this is our everything
fear is irrational we are
absolutely yeah there's some stuff in
those fronts oh the front
pocket is pockets are packed so this is
a little that's happened
pat mcgrath lipstick yep mcgrath lips
you know what i'm so fascinated by the
shape that a woman's
lipstick is it mine's pretty flat yours
goes
flat because you're a virgo you need to
use it all the whole this is fascinating
to me
so my lipsticks which i don't have any
are um
curved like the way let me can you put
lipstick on for us so i can see how you
do it
okay
interesting so you press the whole thing
i'm obsessed with how women put their
own makeup on
you've ever seen when it's like a super
super dipped curve yes yes yes it's like
sharp at the top because every woman no
two women put makeup on the same way
no so when i put lipstick on i hold the
lipstick and move my lips
well it's covered but i know we have no
i've seen
i've seen i've seen you put on lipstick
just like that i like it i put on
lipstick i move my lips
it keeps the lipstick itself insane
looking
yeah and it looks good on you my mom
taught me
uh i learned from her how to put
um lipstick on without a mirror a mirror
which is great
it's a very important lesson what do i
have something no no
i just do that at the end okay um okay
we have you always do that
we have a we always have a lot of
lipsticks light beauty
because you know i love a bold lip as
whitney you love a bold lip
she's um bold lip sharp tongue
and uh cellular syllable
yeah yeah what is this well that this is
a spray it's a it's a silver
you know i'll answer it uh natural
inflammatory support
promotes healthy immune system yeah
spray yeah what's in it
silver placebo oil silver okay so
placebo
over placebo effect is very good
the placebo effect is in effect but
you're gold why silver i don't like the
symbolism of this
silver is very especially in second
during during the pandemic
this i was told it's very good to just
spray so that your throat on your neck
your throat no in your throat so it's
like it blocks
the you know engines it blocks people
talking to you yeah this binds you
that's how you bind yourself
it blocks the droplets because no one
will come near you that's right it makes
sense if you hold this up
and do this no one will there will be no
droplets yeah because people
uh will flee yeah i mean
it works listen it's a repellent yeah i
also have a
i put this is a oh yeah that's good
super lysine
this is all for just to come over to do
the podcast is any of this brand name
like where's it from
like who where where did you purchase
this well so i played
like a at a natural food market on the
side of the road
and then i from my acupuncturist i get
the chinese herbs
got it got it got it got it got it that
tracks a hand purifier oh yeah that's a
good
one okay so we have a hand purifier but
we also have a hand sanitizer oh yeah a
lot
oh no that's deodorant a deodorant
versus a major
hip that's a nice one this is an
all-natural deodorant we're gonna give
you native that's what we do
native sponsors us oh real natural yeah
and better
and you know they can carry it around
because it works all day yeah
yeah well why would you carry around a
deodorant if it worked you wouldn't have
to carry it all day oh yeah
well that's a good point i was using a
deodorant that didn't work and my
husband like very kindly was like
oh that's a bronzer okay so what this is
this is
a makeup bag
[Laughter]
uh you had your hair and makeup done
downstairs correct
so why is all this hair and makeup in
here i don't change my bag out
right so i only add i never subtract
you know what i mean as you should
[Laughter]
i don't go in and go what's today
looking like how should i shift
yeah i'm just like do i have a digestive
enzyme
not sure not going to look going to
throw another one in you know or
do you have to take them throughout the
day though i do i take them with every
meal so this
is my personal favorite vitamin c um
this is called
this is called uh other cocaine so like
for a while i was doing these baggies
where i would write on the baggie in
the bronzer no this is they see the
bronzer you can fade it
called fade into you love the mazzy star
star
the bronzer bronzer is um um
it's like it's like a natural green
brown and that's a great yogurt yeah
yeah i've heard of them i like the
packaging a lot
it's nice isn't it it's a nice one um
this is um that's
these well that's chocolate charcoal but
for who
are you a volcano but you knew what it
was
parkour pills this is a very popular one
before
yet but charcoal pills uh when i
this is a story i've never told before
okay wow when i was
a year old just a tiny babe um
i was at a my mom or my fam
my parents are you into a volcano sorry
threw you into
show versus a volcano is an incredibly
good movie
yeah it is important that we all need to
revisit it at some point patrick shanley
right wrote it i don't know i think so
uh i can say that now
you know what else did you see me not
pretending my kid's three
i want to have tom hanks on the podcast
just to talk about joe versus
yeah it's brilliant joe versus volcano
the first scene of that movie he goes
through
every emo human emotion in one scene
it's incredible and john patrick shanley
also wrote moonstruck which is my other
favorite
and i'm kind of fascinated by meg ryan's
ascent
dissent how her getting like work done
on her face
like canceled her right and how we
just what her her i'm just obsessed with
that that those
women yeah those women yeah it's really
sad
and what and maybe it was her choice i
don't know right could meg ryan work
right now
can you do a retelling of coyote ugly
you think that's in your future
coyote funny because that would be a i
would watch that
coyote beautiful her dad his dad has
killed the most coyotes of anyone in
america
i mean is that true that's what he
thinks he has a habit
you're not going to tell him otherwise
coyote king how's he kill him
what's ways oh god mostly guns but
well he's the coyote king right yeah
they call him wild bill cody king
oh my god wow that's really impressive
and bap-bap-baps about coyote it means
scaring coyotes off
is it yeah because you have to that's
what you got it's girl gotta scare them
somehow
charcoal oh yeah so you are it is used
to diffuse
i mean basically absorb toxins toxins in
the body yeah
and when i was a year old i was crawling
around and i took a pill on the floor
of someone's house and it was a
painkiller
what sounds like yesterday
did i say one year i meant a day
one day ago around my house i found a
bill
i took it and now we're here
and um went unconscious
no went to the hospital died
what died uh she's been a ghost ever
since oh my god that makes so much sense
i pit i i died when i was a year old
they put charcoal
down my throat that's what they do when
you've back then certainly
they pump your stomach charcoal came
back alive
so i is that the whole story
guys i died they covered me in charcoal
i risen me jesus easter my birthday
guess what that's about me you guys
didn't know
that's why i used charcoal toothpaste to
this day yes it was it was 1818.
i cut they covered me in leeches okay i
had maggots in my wounds
charcoal right in the throat born again
i know it is bathing is blowing wait
wait you can't take charcoal if you're
taking medication
that's right because it will absorb them
but birth control and such
learn that the hard way yeah by literal
yeah other yeah yeah so you take this
every day charcoal
no you can't take it every day how do
you have toxins in you you don't have
any why would you need charcoal if you
never eat tacos can you believe we could
have cured death
but why would someone that eats so pure
take charcoal
it's a maxi i haven't seen one of these
in
so long got to be prepared maxi packs
don't shame her did you not watch the
craft
yeah exactly how dare you i the fact
that the reason you and i bonded so hard
is when i got in your car in kentucky
you had tampons in your car
and i created ones and i said why do you
have tampons in your car would you say i
have a lot of female friends and they
already have to buy so many
that's incredible oh my god that is
beautiful that is fucking
allyship isn't it this is not
it is you hate yourself no i love what
is this
that is in case just in case
the panty liner that's right but i'll
tell you what
scented you can smell no it's not
scented it's it's organic
and it smells like a pad and i will say
eight dollars i will say that
that um the thing that i'm really into
now
yes is uh those switches
is um like period underwear oh carla
welch
harlow welch carlos yeah it's period i
thought you meant period under like
period piece
i was like like a victorian underwear
i'm wearing
i'm wearing underwear from the agent
where's bloom jenny does
bloomers yeah so um carla welch
who uh you all know because she styled
me
for my hbo special called i'm your
girlfriend
when i wore the black blazer and the
heel the french heels i looked
parisian like a puri and um
a uh a vintage camisole and a ball mat
jacket that i still owe money on um
i saw that live you saw it live it was
so fun
were you there the second night or the
first time was there the first night the
first night when the air conditioning
didn't i didn't i hadn't yet i wasn't
unbound yet
yeah and uh the biggest
problem with shooting specials is that
the building
um doesn't know everything the comedian
knows
uh and i remember going it's gonna be
hot in there they're not gonna turn the
air conditioning on i need to
cause you to turn the air conditioning
on the day before directors know this
like comedians know this and i remember
going like
uh i need to tell him and i was like you
know what winnie don't i hadn't
connected to my source yet i was like
you're being crazy because i was
conditioned to believe that i'm crazy i
micromanaged i'm i'm nuts i'm insane
i mean i had a show runner that we
worked with sit me down and say
if you keep acting like this like people
are going to think you're roseanne
and then i went on to ep roseanne um
and you had died earlier so that i was
already dead frankly
um and uh and i was like don't say
anything don't be annoying don't be
difficult
you're already pushing it yeah and i
went in the first
uh night uh you were there a lot of
people
a lot of people came yeah and i went on
stage
right within the first 30 seconds beat a
sweat i'm sweating
yeah i'm shiny i mean look i'm shiny
that's my shit yeah that's that's your
brand that's my brand yeah but sweating
is my thing so
i was plagiarizing um so i was like
oh fuck and i'm like none of this is
usable and i knew that
you're in your head the whole that whole
first night was usable but also the
first
uh taping of a stand-up special is
always a camera rehearsal anyway
but i was it was so great though but i
had people there that i like respected
and loved and i didn't do my best
um and carla welch who styled me uh for
that
went on to uh be a fat she does sarah
paulson and all this she's just tracy
she's just an amazing stylist yeah like
she's just she's the first stylist in
hollywood that didn't try to make me
just look like a
thot like she was the first style like i
went through all these stylists that
that would just try to make me look like
a rapper
legend i literally was about to say
i mean i did it letterman google me on
letterman the my first letterman i'm in
an actual airva
leger this style you're about to give us
the weather
[Laughter]
this this stylist by the way is dead no
she died
yeah was she
she got food put she got her some
charcoal
um yeah bring her pants get her charcoal
and she was the first person that like
put me in pants uh carla well she was
like oh yeah you're
um katherine hepburn yeah yeah like wow
and uh uh so carla welsh put me in
the little um okay let's we'll get to
that in a minute
um yeah carla welsh uh it made these
period panties
yeah they're downstairs in my living
room which is great
better for the environment yeah yes
yeah yes so i'm all about that insect
repellent
yeah yeah you took your iud out are you
were you at the lake
like where would you sometimes where
would you be anywhere what bugs
i have i know white women get lime i
have very sweet blood
oh yes and the mosquitoes love
it's all the silver and the craft was
shot in the forest
the craft yeah that's right it was shot
in the forest oh no i love all the
tie-ins thank you for bringing it back
on track
those are fiber pills this is jetblue
mint okay guys
dexter reboot
i think that's my birth certificate
passport
a copy of the passport this is a
this is an order don't you keep a
picture on your are you on the run
are you you're gone girl are you
planning to leave daryl do you need to
be able to escape at any moment
what i didn't realize that i was like
such a okay
why is everything in a bag is this
evidence
for something are you a fbi agent the
fact that this is
the fact that this is where you draw you
know how like with the glove and the
bags it's just like she was like and
we're gonna put this to evidence
you know how us weekly does like what's
in my bag
you take this so that this one works
these work together
i don't know what those are and that's
the problems
okay oh good shape empty oh no shades
no shades no shade but okay
i mean i haven't really the wallet
that's just so open yeah oh we love that
okay so that you have the copy of the
license but the license is here but
thank god you have the copy of your well
that's my passport just because you'd go
international yeah and then a bunch of
um bitch has received
that's very rare you gotta have cash the
thing with the most germs is cash
yeah but it's really like spins
okay oh my god i just want you guys to
know i don't think this is good for my
brand
you know to call this out no well it's
it's it's but i really i'm this part of
my issue and something that i'm trying
to confirm
this is okay so this one one is loose
and one is pretty
single-handedly keeping them in business
so this powder
is so that the loose powder yeah they
work together they work together
yeah it's about in being in community
yeah that's right that's right it's not
the um
this one doesn't threaten this one no
symbiotic
so like what i need and this is what i
know that i need
there's a lot of therapy here's her
toothpick toothpick
for hors d'oeuvres i will have a
viennese sausage thank you
okay okay got a prep yeah yeah
yeah just in case for her um gynecology
side hustle
okay a pen yeah well that's yeah that's
awesome yeah that's important
cute sweet okay yeah and then
the oh some tulsi yeah you know some
love oh that's poo poo i'm just
neosporin
oh i have that too you do in your bag
okay aquaphor
like what i need is i need a number of
smaller bags and i have attempted this
in the past
this is all i just want you guys to know
this is all just a one
i mean this is wait but are you taking
are you taking all these and then
refilling the baggies and putting them
back in your bag
please tell me there's sunglasses in
there is there sunglasses please tell me
there's sunglasses
please tell me because this is where it
starts to get dark you know what
thank you thank god there is a pair of
very chic sunglasses those are nice
oh thank god okay good but do you take
all these vitamins and then like refill
the bag
no it's it's not about taking them out
or are you just filling up these bags
and carrying them around foreign
here's what i'll say the value of having
vitamins a lot of times is just knowing
you have them
yeah that's that's the yeah it's sort of
like through osmosis
yeah because through the backpack i'm
getting the name i don't take
vitamins what's the difference honestly
there's no difference i have this is a
wellness show really and so this is
really i'm teaching a lot of people
yeah we'll have to get about again
explain what all this stuff is i mean
part of the
thing is that i do take all of my i'm
very good at taking my vitamins
you do yeah you do but it's a ritual i
mean it's also
about you cooperation and productivity
makes dopamine
so a lot of times what we're getting
from taking vitamins even if it is doing
nothing for you
it is it is producing dopamine the fact
that you have the placebo of it that you
have a ritual that you
check a box yes that you have a schedule
so it's like if you
work out and don't have an idea of what
you're gonna do you're gonna go oh that
was a shitty word
like the ideas too and gary goldman when
he was on talked about this with
depression is that you
set goals and achieve them and when you
achieve a goal if you have no goals and
don't achieve them then you feel
listless and like i didn't achieve and
i'm a failure and i suck and
what builds self-esteem is doing
esteemable actions which means
accomplishing goals
so i'm gonna take this vitamin every
morning it doesn't matter if it's
actually vitamin c if it's
who gives a shit it's the fact that
you're taking it and being consistent
that builds self-esteem
right um but believe it or not this is
your that is a bag you only pulled
medicine and vitamins out of that bag
you're just carrying a medicine cabinet
around your back that's what
absolutely yeah that is a joke in the
whitney pilot
it was dr quinn yeah i think that's like
what got us picked up
really that dr quinn dr
quinn i also there was a kegel joke in
the pilot as well i'm that
sounds attractive um yeah it's mostly
it's mostly inviting right now i'm doing
them right now yeah
which i am um it's mostly vitamins and
obviously you saw some beauty
some some beauty products
one one pair of sunglasses and one club
but
but we are but we're doing the exact
thing she's
of all the the um and we're gonna close
on this
we're shaming her for being the most
prepared we're shaming her for getting
ahead of it we're shaming her who is we
that's right i take full resp i take
responsibility i was cut out of that
video yeah give my glasses
joke yeah turn it to black and white um
i we make fun of
the highly evolved you know this is all
the most prepared mm-hmm and the least
organized
i think it's organized it's organized to
you
i mean you know where it is kind of
i do a lot of digging turns out you're
not a perfectionist also not a virgo but
that's the thing is when you go into my
cabinets like my house everything is
like
very very tidy which is why you made the
new craft
but if you open a drawer it is a mess
which is also maybe just like the art
the artist
drawers are confusing what even goes in
a drawer you know what i mean like if
there's hot
tape benches
kitchen drawers like that's just what if
it goes in there anything
anything you want had junk
you're making me feel like i'm high why
like what's a drawer
well if you had water if your kitchen
wasn't all cabinets you would know
listen i think because this is about the
craft
um i brought runes oh my gosh so you can
cast
and then we can like do them so these
rooms are made out of bones
because the which lady getting can i
bought them
from was like it's nice to have
something that's like you
to cast you know what i mean so these
are bone rooms so let's you can cast
someone
see what they say i've never cast a roon
okay so what you're going to do is
there's a couple ways you can do it you
can close the bag up and shake it and
then dump the bag out
or you can just pick some out with your
hand and sprinkle them however you want
so and how many should i pick out it's
up to you
okay
i didn't realize there were so many
okay okay just scatter them
okay flip them over
they that's what she said but you know i
mean they could be lying okay
okay now all i have to do is find all
those runes
oh that's one of them that is one of
them i found one it's
okay let's see what it means
oh it's up right okay great so this
means that
sorry people listening and not watching
on youtube you're going to
overcome opposition uh you will uh
fulfill individual needs and plans
you're going to have a big win there'll
be no opposing forces working against
you for this
a fortunate new career opportunity will
come your way based on a
past opportunity
um this rune signifies that sometimes
that you may feel like the timing is not
right for a new beginning currently due
to circumstances throughout the world
but it's always a good time to go after
your dreams
my personal journal truly
that's amazing and let's see what
another bullet point
don't expect bad things expect the best
in dark times
that's hard you have to throw your
backpack out
because we expect bad things that's why
we that's what i'm doing
and i think that i'm going to be able to
control the outcome and when we say in
pro
we say in program is when you forgive
people you take bricks out of your
backpack because you're carrying your
resemblance around oh my god my backpack
is so heavy
i know radical forgiveness yeah
okay so the middle one uh the straight
line
is about an emotional relationship you
may have felt there is a breach in
loyalty but right now you feel all
disloyalty
easing away and you feel like all your
shortcomings are coming to a resolve
in a fairly short amount of time that
everything you have going on is
salvageable hmm and you see
big plans this is a lot about plans yeah
someone watching do it any faster than
that i mean i only can read the book as
fast i can find the room well having to
find the room people watching
this is not how you do this and then
this one
the first one says that you should
um take caution of all your careful
thoughts and sometimes just go with how
you feel without overthinking
oh boy um advice is given freely to you
and you should give advice freely back
look at your surroundings and take the
leap you don't have to overthink and
mother everything
whitney's entertainment also says that
you should look into apprenticeships
gifting your trade to other people and
learning a new trade for yourself you
never know where it could take
oh i love that benton thank you so much
that was such a gift
and i want to get some runes because i
used to do the iching
which is do you know about that it's
sort of similar but it's like a sort of
like a fortune telling yeah well i'll
give you these rooms you know they say
you're not
yeah you have these they say that you're
not supposed to buy your own like tarot
cards or runes or stuff
you're supposed to gift them to people
so you just have those
thank you so much this is the best day
of my life
i mean it kind of actually is though and
it is lovely if i'm not in the sequel
it is this has been the most emotional
uh podcast
i've ever been a part of truly
this is the only podcast i've ever been
on camera with a guest for really
yeah maybe i just make it better no way
it was incredible it was incredible to
have you uh be a part of this
conversation because the original craft
is so meaningful to you and like
that is so it's it's so
um like i was telling you before it's
such a relief to hear
from someone who loves the original so
much i told you it took so much
it took so much bravery to make the
movie to begin with because also it's
important to know a lot of people are
gonna there's gonna be negativity why
are you not talking about
we're no longer a part of this why are
you over there and not here
are you doing none i'm done i'm standing
now but we're
yeah dave's done now we're done we're
done we finished
the the one thing i'll say is is that
there there are going to be people
that there's going to be negative as
someone that has dealt with backlash
that was half about me it's like because
we become
projection machine right we're mirrors
right so you just become
a mirror like a lot of energy's going to
come at you positive
and negative but it's all just energy
yeah well i felt so much positive energy
here today so i want to thank you both
for all of that
because it was really so when any other
kind of energy
comes at you it's it's not about you
it's not it's not about you it's just
kicking up
yeah it's you're healing people yeah
you're giving up the ability find it
move on
find yourself find it and move on find
it and move on
unbound people are very triggering to
bound people that's right
absolutely right don't ride elephants i
love you guys
you